Ah ah ah ah ah, oh, da da da, da da.
Welcome back, Master.
Hello, hello, hello!
Oh my gosh, I saw... I saw someone say one last trip to mid-world.
That's true!
Oh my gosh, you're right!
It's the last time!
I didn't even think about that!
That's crazy!
Oh my god, how are you feeling, Minto?
Actually, I just, like, right before the stream, had like a killer migraine.
So I'm really glad that it's gone.
Maybe!
So I might be a little bit low energy because of that.
But, yeah!
Last of 2.0.
Yes.
Oh my gosh!
I'll miss the intro and outro so much.
I actually...
I was kind of stressing because...
As of this morning, I was missing 3 major things.
No, sorry, 4 major things for my re-debut, which is tomorrow!
Oh my god.
I get migraines once a month.
Oh, I'm sending you good vibes.
Thank you!
That might actually be why I had a migraine.
Maybe.
I didn't think about that, actually.
But I was missing 4 major things.
And I got 2 of them today.
One of them was actually my new intro.
And I got it this morning and I was like...
It's so good!
And...
I got another thing that I needed.
And then the 2 last things that I need are basically finished.
So, oh my gosh.
Everything...
Actually, I'm waiting... Well, there is one thing, but if I don't have it done, that's okay.
Basically.
It's one of the guests for karaoke.
So, yeah.
Oh my god.
Everything has been so last minute, but that's okay.
I kind of was just like...
So...
Less than 24 hours to go.
Yeah, baby!
Oh my god.
But did Minto receive a new heart that loves wisps?
I guess you'll have to see.
I wouldn't get your hopes up, though.
So...
Sounds super stressful.
I thought I had faith.
I had faith.
I think.
But, oh my gosh, now I'm even more excited because everything just looks so good!
Yippee!
No, you played, Faith.
Oh, yeah.
Tomorrow, tomorrow.
I love you, tomorrow.
It's only a day away.
And tomorrow is also Chri...
Not Christmas.
Oh my god.
It's gonna feel like Christmas.
It's Halloween!
It's basically my Christmas.
Halloween is my Christmas.
It's my Christmas.
Why did I almost say Christmas?
Christmas hype.
No, we still have a Halloween to get through.
Please.
I don't want to think about Christmas until November 1st.
Then what is Christmas?
Double Christmas.
Santa's coming early.
I know, and there's so much happening, I think, tomorrow, too.
I mean, of course there's always gonna be a lot happening.
With streamers on a holiday.
Hopefully, despite all the fun activities that you might see going on wherever you're watching.
Twitch or YouTube.
Whatever, wherever.
Whatever, whenever, wherever.
You will hopefully find some time to drop by my little debut.
It shouldn't be so long.
Probably like two hours.
If you are like, oh my gosh, I can't watch everything in one day.
It's not gonna be left finger point, right finger point.
It's not gonna be, you know, like all day event or anything.
But, yeah, very excited.
Didn't expect Shakira today.
I stand for Thanksgiving.
See, I felt like this game was a nice transition from Halloween into the fall.
If you're a US-American, Thanksgiving kind of vibe is going on.
You know, I thought, I was like, hmm.
Do I wanna end our Halloween spooky month on a really scary game?
Or do I want to do like more of a, kind of a feels-y vibe.
And, you know, this one's a nice feels-y vibe.
So, there is no fall in Texas.
But you got the yeehaw.
I am not a US-American.
You know what, that's okay too.
We can all appreciate fall.
And even if we live in a place that doesn't have fall, we can all pretend.
You know, just crank that AC up.
And be like, ah, what a brisk morning.
Oh, wait, not up.
Down.
Crank it down.
And be like, what a fall crisp morning.
And light that pumpkin candle.
Yeah.
Don't have AC.
Turn on your fan.
Yeah.
Or something.
I don't know, get a hand fan.
You want me to hand hold you through all the steps?
How to create a fall?
I don't know, I don't know.
Figure it out Google, wiki how.
Do it.
How to Google.
Yes.
But yeah, if you don't know this game, it is another game that I have played before.
I'm sorry that, I guess this month has kind of been a couple games that I've played through before.
Actually, maybe that's been the past couple of months since I've been going through Metal Gear again too.
Throwback October.
DMC1 was new.
Yeah.
Wait, what else have I done that was like not new, let's see.
Things that I've played before.
So sorry if it's not like a fresh reaction.
But it's been a minute since I've played this game, so...
It's kind of like a fresh reaction.
Let's see.
Okay, so I played Faith.
Oh, Spooky's Jump Scare Mansion, that was new.
Over the Garden Wall, that was not new.
Grunt, that was new.
No, Peggle...
It was Peggle Extreme, it wasn't normal Peggle.
The Bath House?
Well, it was a different version of the Bath House.
Eternal Darkness?
Oh wait, I'm into September already.
But that was still new, you know.
Mario Party?
Yeah, it was a new Mario Party.
Yeah.
I experienced, but I experienced an old feeling.
The feeling of getting screwed over.
In Mario Party.
MGS was new?
How was MGS new?
Turtle, it's your birthday!
Of course I can sing happy birthday!
Oh my gosh, I like your profile picture.
What an awesome drawing.
So cool.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Turtle.
Happy birthday!
But yeah, so...
Hopefully you don't mind.
If I replay this...
A little bit.
Sloppy Sisters were new?
True, true, true.
A pretty cool artist drew it for me.
Yeah, I bet they're so awesome.
Cool.
Okay.
Oh, I don't know this game, it's new to me?
Awesome!
Then...
No spoilers, everybody.
No spoilers.
I'm going to try for the good end.
But no promises.
I tried looking...
I'm not going to lie.
I tried looking up like a guide of how to get the good end.
And...
Nothing would tell me.
So no spoilers for people in the chat.
Okay?
Okay, let's start.
Oh, icky.
Spooky.
Little frog, she's so cute.
Sorry, I'm like adjusting audio.
It's our guy.
You just put those on.
Oh my gosh, I thought the rock was snoring.
I thought the rock was asleep.
Oh, to be a pinecone elf.
Oh my god.
I hope we didn't need that.
He's so chill about it.
He's like, wow, okay.
Forgot about the little fox in this.
How could you forget about Benjamin?
Benjamin.
Be aware.
Oh my god, Stanley Parable.
Narrator.
I love rewards!
What will my reward be?
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
I forgot my...I forgot my hat!
This is Miss Fortune.
Sorry guys, I forgot my little hat.
A little sparkle for you, and a little sparkle for you, and a little bit for me.
What's that?
No!
Spoiler.
Okay, narrator.
She's like, maybe we should bring that part up again.
We're dying to meet you!
Wait, am I going to go back to heaven?
I sure hope not.
Am I going to cross on over?
Maybe we shouldn't have said deal.
Leave the house.
Click on left mouse button to walk.
Oh, it's like a click?
Okay.
Left mouse button to interact.
Okay, left mouse button for everything.
Let's go inside.
Happy spoopy day, Minto!
Australia!
Happy Halloween!
How's the audio by the way?
How's the audio?
If it's okay.
It's good?
Okay.
I feel like this is a really... What's the word?
It's a very audio driven kind of game.
I try to let them speak more than me.
A little bit.
Who's Bubsy?
Who cares about Bubsy?
Leave the book for Bubsy?
What the heck is a Bubsy?
I'm taking it with me.
Kinda cool.
Can you wish my friend Honch?
Honch a happy birthday.
Please don't fall.
I'm just trying to figure out what it is.
That seems sus.
I know.
It does seem sus.
Honch...
Trois.
Honch Trois?
I don't... What?
Honch.
Oh, is it supposed to be like the Honch Tour?
No, it's Honch.
Trois.
It's French.
I guess I hear the tour.
Trois.
It's like a fancy version.
Honch Trois.
Coloring book.
Nice.
Oh, what is that?
Creepy stories.
She's just like me for real for real.
I used to have so many books like that.
I mean, that's a ghost.
It's just, you know.
But you just said nobody's allowed to read it.
Miss Fortune Damirez Hernandez.
I like to play a lot with my toys.
I like to talk to them because it's fun.
Cute.
Hello diary.
At school I drew and at home I was at my hiding spot talking to Bubsy and I heard it.
I saw a fox walking outside my room.
He's called Benjamin, I think.
Benjamin.
That fox.
Oh my goodness.
Hello diary.
My dad lied to me again.
Not going out to the park today.
I made myself pretty but he doesn't care.
I feel sad.
I cried but told mommy I'm okay.
I'm afraid if I tell her I'm sad, she'll be angry.
Sometimes I don't know how to feel.
Nobody is teaching me how to feel.
I wish in school they'd teach us where feelings come from.
But for reals.
No fairy tales.
She has like the cleanest handwriting.
Ever.
Yikes forever.
Oh my god.
Hello diary.
Is it okay to have feelings for a fox?
Misfortune watched Disney's Robin Hood for the first time ever.
Zootopia.
I guess Zootopia would be a more modern way.
Does anybody even watch the...
Do kids even watch Robin Hood anymore?
I don't know.
I think Robin Hood is more...
Still more charming than...
What's his name?
The guy from Zootopia.
I think he was always...
The guy from Zootopia is kind of a bit of a whiny dude.
Nick, yeah, yeah, Nick.
Nick Wilde.
Is that his name?
Your age is showing Minto.
What are you talking about?
Robin Hood is a classic.
What do you think?
I was born in...
When did I come out?
In like the 60's or something crazy?
When did I die?
Oh no, I don't know.
Uh oh.
That Robin Hood really stuck with you, huh Mint?
Oh my gosh, yes.
I'm not the...
I feel entirely valid.
I feel entirely valid in having a crush on the Robin Hood.
Thoughts on the Fantastic Mr. Fox?
I never saw it, it's creepy.
I never watched it.
Like, Robin Hood is just way too...
And then Maid Marian...
It's... Literally Robin Hood is for everybody.
Everybody can have...
A crush...
In Robin Hood.
They're both so hot.
Girl, you're so valid.
I knew you'd have my back.
Robin Hood's a criminal?
But he's a good criminal.
He's like...
Batman.
Batman shouldn't be beating people up, that's a crime.
You don't see anybody being like, oh Batman, that guy deserves to go in jail.
Yeah, the anti-hero.
Yeah, but Batman is Batman.
Yeah, and Robin Hood is Robin Hood.
As long as they're charismatic, who cares.
Isn't that how it goes?
As long as you have the charisma.
The Rizma.
If you have the Rizma, then you are...
Okay.
That's how all the stories go.
The Rizma.
That's what it is.
I also puke too.
All the time, not just in love.
I don't feel right.
And Sean Connery never played Batman.
Eggy sushi.
Oh my god.
My Japanese friend speaks Japanese.
That's very problematic when we want to talk.
I thought she was calling him speaking Japanese problematic.
Oh my god, everybody cancel Hiro.
That guy can only speak Japanese, it's problematic.
It's hard to understand each other.
It's confusing.
But I like him.
He has a pair of sweet boots and a cowboy hat.
His name is Hiro and he's a ghost.
Just like me.
I drew a picture of him.
Oh wait, I drew a picture.
Wait, sorry.
I drew him a picture.
Oh my god, my dyslexia.
But I never gave it to him.
Oh my gosh, I want to be friends with Miss Fortune so she can say that about me too.
Hello diary.
Look, I have glitter from Sewell.
It's super shiny and we use it to make Christmas cards.
I think Christmas cards are pretty.
But I don't believe Santa is for reals.
If a man could give everyone a gift, why can't he give poor people water and food?
Oh my gosh, Miss Fortune is already thinking about such things.
Where is your cowboy hat?
I never got one.
They never gave me one at the ghost academy.
I saw a TV show with people from other countries having nothing to eat.
Anyway, I don't believe Santa is real.
There's people starving in the world.
Anyway...
But the glitter is amazing.
It makes me think that all the...
Wait, that...
All that makes me sad and angry can be sprinkled with sparkle to make prettier.
Wait, to look prettier.
What's wrong?
I can't read today either.
That makes me a little less sad.
Glitter.
I love my glitter.
Glitter!
Hello diary, I went picking tomatoes with my grandma.
It smelled so nice.
I saw butterflies, some other insects too.
I ate two tomatoes and then I was stuffed.
I made a real nice drawing there.
You see?
Yes, very nice.
I did the coloring too.
Impressive.
Inside the lines...
Mostly.
Miss Fortune, we need to talk about down there.
A little bit.
And this part you didn't finish, you didn't fill in.
The shading is...
Where is the light direction coming from?
And this one just has no shading at all.
Abysmal.
Her art isn't going to get any likes or retweets.
It's true!
It's true.
Two out of ten.
Hello diary, I was riding my tricycle.
We don't have money for the bicycle and I looked straight in the sun.
And I started crying because it hurt my eyes.
My mommy said that one should not look directly at it.
At least her mom is teaching her something.
Hello diary, it was fun today because I was at the lake and I saw birds flying and also fish in the water.
I felt like warm water came near my bottom.
What does that mean?
I peed in the lake.
It was really warm.
She has the look of someone peeing in the lake, doesn't she?
Just like that thousand yard stare.
I'm sure the fish appreciated it.
It's like some sort of nutrients, right?
Hello diary, how are you?
I'm good too.
I have to do homework, but I can't stop thinking about Benjamin.
I found a picture of me when I was younger.
Time goes fast.
The cake looks yummy.
Very cute.
She's a lady.
She's a little lady.
Babycorn, thanks for the gift card!
The ammonia is good for the algae.
Halloween.
Halloween costumes idea.
Little lady fox.
This is sick.
Actually, both of these...
Are these stickers or did she draw these?
They look so good.
That's it for the diary.
Awesome.
This is Bubsy, the guardian of the secret spot.
You see his eye?
He got that from a battle against a monster.
Scary.
I think we did everything in here then.
Cool.
So that's Bubsy.
Sorry Bubsy, I took your thing.
Oh, I can walk around with...
Benjamin!
For tomorrow's show, we waited with baited moods.
But you should know tonight, you're pretty good.
Thanks, Brian!
Benjamin.
Okay.
Nobody asked.
What?
She runs.
She looks kind of... Why does she got that look on her face?
I like to move my body.
It's the music that goes on forever.
I hope this is copyright free.
I hope I don't get struck by YouTube.
I hope my channel won't be taken down.
She's got some moves.
Forever.
Dance, dance, yeah.
Oh, get it.
Misfortune.
Oh, break it down.
Oh yeah.
And kick, kick, bounce, bounce, kick, kick, bounce, bounce, kick, kick.
Kick, kick, kick.
Okay.
Thank you.
Your rock is kind of bloody over there, I think.
Take the glitter!
Nice.
Click on misfortune to throw glitter.
Now this is important.
You might see me spamming glitter a little bit.
You might see me spamming the glitter a little bit.
For those who have not played the game...
It's important.
I saw a monster in here once.
I showed it the finger and it never came back.
You show a misfortune.
She's so metal sometimes.
She's kind of odd.
I love her so much.
She's just...
She's so badass.
Oh, we can take a toy?
You can only choose one.
And remember, your choice is much more important than you think.
Okay.
I choose...
Unicorn or stone?
I don't remember.
Wait.
I think we should...
I don't remember which is important.
Never seen a unicorn?
I don't think I have either.
Stone is a better weapon.
Stone for throwing things.
It is a rock fact.
Tossing glitter to fill our dark souls with light.
I want to bring the stone.
But I don't remember what the difference is to be honest.
Unicorn has the horn though.
True.
Steven.
Sorry, I want to bring the stone.
Stoney.
The narrator is so nice.
Oh my god.
Fabulous.
Yeah!
The glitter is a chaff.
A bit me-me.
Benjamin!
Well, we keep it a secret, huh?
Wait, is there anything in here I can glitter real quick?
I don't think so actually.
Why is the sound effect so loud for the glitter?
Let's see.
How old is Miss Fortune?
I still don't quite understand.
Oh no!
Don't fall!
I didn't mean...
It's ok.
We'll just glitter it.
Hold on, I was trying to read some of this though.
Did mommy find out who did it?
Miss Fortune!
That's kind of the same thing.
Maybe I could try to fix it.
Fix it!
We got this.
We can fix it.
Oh, we're actually fixing it.
Let's see.
Wait.
This goes like around here-ish.
But this goes...
Wait, this goes...
This goes there.
And then this goes there.
And this goes...
There.
I can't say the darndest things.
Right, Minto?
Wait, this goes there.
We're doing it!
And in the flower.
Perfect!
Oh my gosh, the cars.
Fix the vase.
Wait, if I glitter...
Even when I'm sad.
Oh my god.
Uh-huh.
It's the nervous laughter at the end of every sentence.
It's the little...
Oh my god.
I forgot just how much this game is a little, you know...
Yeah, there's nothing else.
Oh my goodness.
I don't know how to explain it.
Juice.
I am.
What's in here?
Misfortune.
Misfortune, shut the door!
Yeah, that's good.
Shut the door, Misfortune!
Thank you.
Mushrooms!
Yuck.
Yikes forever.
It's a real yikes forever moment, yeah.
Can you just imagine?
You're trying to cook.
You're trying to make something for dinner.
And, like, your kid comes up and just throws glitter into it.
Into the big pot of boiling soup.
And it's just, like, ruining the meal.
Yikes forever.
Wait, what was that?
Oh, here.
That didn't clean up though.
Juice!
Okay, we got three sparkles.
Oh, it's October 11th.
No, that was like two weeks ago.
Tell mommy you're leaving?
Yeah, we'll see.
We're a good kid.
I'm going out to play, mommy!
So cute.
Good morning, Minto!
Nervous laughter.
She has a nervous laughter just like me.
For real, for real.
Remember Benjamin the fox?
This is where I first saw him.
Good afternoon!
Morning!
Wait.
Good morning!
Minto afternoon!
It was really intense.
Yes, you told me about that fox already.
That fox.
You shouldn't trust a fox.
They're all criminals.
What?
A fox criminal?
That's silly.
How can an animal be a criminal?
Stupid narrator.
Does he know anything?
Stomped out!
Oh my god, the cat is so cute.
Daddy?
Where is he?
Happiness to the cat!
Oh, the cat has a little symbol.
Rest in pepperoni, the homeboy Peter Rabbit.
Why does misfortune creepily sound like tenma?
I don't know.
I can't pinpoint what the accent is.
Hello kitty.
Here, come.
Come kitty.
Kitty, kitty.
Kitty!
No!
Why are you so mean?
Oh god.
Be careful.
Look both ways before crossing the street.
Maybe you shouldn't yell at them.
Okay, should we listen?
Should we listen?
Consequences.
Sounds like Until Dawn.
Okay, should we listen?
Swedish.
It's Swedish.
Okay.
Why are there so many spooky games with moose people?
I think...can I press space to...no.
Okay, so I have to click on her to activate...
Put a little blanket on him.
He's a little tired.
Animated intro.
A little misfortune.
Not enough horror games with moth people?
Why do you want more moth people?
It's raining on her.
Look at her.
She sees the...
She sees the good in everything even though she's just an unlucky little kid.
Oh god!
And everybody in there died.
Oh my god!
That was a close one.
Oh, it did also...I think the glitter sets things on fire maybe.
Oh my gosh.
She's actually, like, related to...
Like a Shinigami or something.
Yeah, why'd you go out this far?
Misfortune.
Now focus, Misfortune.
You have to make a very difficult choice regarding this puppy now.
Be aware of the consequences.
I don't...this scares me.
Oh gosh.
He's all ready for the party.
What if he's trying to get to the party?
We might have to set him free to get to the party.
Play with the pupper?
Yeah,
but...
Freedom.
He longs for freedom.
Beware the bus?
Oh yeah, you're right, true.
He can run away and then get...
Play in the road?
Ok, we'll play with him.
I will play with it so we can share a nice time together.
What?
What do you mean throw the ball at it?
No, you throw the ball away.
So that he can go and run and catch it.
It's not throw the ball at the puppy.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, he literally became a pancake.
I think that puppy wasn't real.
Look at the way it's smooshed.
I think it was like a plushie.
You guys, it was like a squish animal.
It's ok, we're fine.
What accident?
I'm not coping.
I'm just...
No.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, you can still pet the dog?
Do you think that's in one of those... that database of you can pet the animal?
Can I take the ball?
Yeah, puppy killer.
Red ball puppy killer.
Everybody, all my homies hate red balls.
Nice.
What does this say?
It says no dogs allowed.
Oh, really?
Well then, I think the tree was just following protocol.
The tree is actually...
It's a tree person.
You can see there, they have a little cutout for the face.
They're holding branches.
It actually... he's a snitch, the tree.
Balance was achieved.
Oh my goodness.
Oh god!
Miss Fortune!
What is wrong with you?
Let's just keep going.
Let's work here.
Okay.
Oh wait, your vomit too?
We can even observe that?
Oh, okay.
The narrator is speaking for all of us?
Why is she eating the glitter?
I told you she put it in the soup, you guys.
Oh, where are we?
Recycling.
Oh, what's this?
That sign doesn't work.
Do you see all the crap lying around?
So true!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Oh yeah, we're going to party!
We're going to the party.
There is so much trash.
Glitter to the...
What the?
She looks like this happens all the time.
She looks so fed up with them.
She's like I can't...
Okay.
Oh, kick them in the balls or throw glitter at the birds.
I don't think birds have balls.
Yeah!
Oh true, actually.
Oh, it worked.
Oh.
She's just chilling.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
It's the bird!
This game is so dumb.
And save.
Such a rude bird.
True.
Yeah, we had the best parachute ever.
Is this the same lake she swam in?
This is why I don't swim in lakes.
George?
Oh.
Will you tell George about the puppy accident?
I think George deserves to know.
But then also George left his dog there.
Honesty is the best policy.
I think so too.
Miss Fortune is a good girl.
Aww.
I can't believe this lake has just a never ending bridge on it.
Oh!
Oh, he can take the fish with us.
Free fish, yeah!
I'm gonna take it.
I'll keep it.
Do lakes usually have a bridge like this across it though?
Oh, he's...
It's a little slimy.
He'll probably be fine.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure this will make a fine slab of sushi.
This fresh, fresh fish from this trash lake.
George!
Hi Mint, hello!
Hello!
I didn't read the subtitles, so I thought she said stupid.
I thought she was like stupid, I'm doing it for the puppy.
Oh no!
Ok, this fish needs a friend.
Ping pong!
Rodrigo?
You mean Codrigo?
Time to check out the party!
The party!
We're gonna party!
Tomorrow we'll party.
I saw a man who was floating in the lake, just like this fisher.
He was sunbathing.
Surely, he was just practicing his float.
What a nice picture.
I wish I had a picture like this with my mommy and daddy.
Hello?
What is it, Miss Fortune?
Nothing.
He spooked me!
Why are sometimes ghosts so weird about what they can do?
Gosh!
Do I scare you guys?
Wait, but that's the kid in the picture.
I guess he's dead.
Are you sure this is the right house?
Where is the party?
Yes, all the time!
You guys are too nice.
Is there anything we can sparkle in here?
I wanna make sure I don't miss anything, you know?
Excuse me, are you George?
Oh, Miss Fortune.
Are you the owner of a puppy?
Because I bring really bad news.
I'm just hanging out, man.
There's no party today.
Like a piata?
Should I hit him like a piata?
Oh, Miss Fortune!
He's dead.
Dead?
But he's wearing a pair of sweet boots.
He can't be dead.
You know if you got sweet boots on, you can't be dead, you guys.
Okay.
Hey, Miss Fortune, I think this party's over.
Let's leave.
I'll meet you in the back.
The guy didn't even finish his croissant.
Now that you're dead, your puppy is gone.
I like the puppy.
Bye.
After Sunday, you will forever instill fear in me if you sing the Monster Mash again.
Why wait until Sunday?
Oh.
Don't call him a piata.
No, Miss Fortune!
Don't call him that.
I guess he's so sad about his son.
He's so sad.
Check the painting?
Oh wait.
Oh no, I didn't check the painting!
I'm so sorry, I didn't see it.
Do you think I can go back?
Or did it save?
Wait, does that mean I don't get the good end?
Oh no!
Oh, it doesn't affect the ending?
Okay.
You guys scared me.
You don't need it?
Okay, okay, okay.
It's just extra.
I think you guys can look it up if you want to know.
Really?
I hate the woods.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's kicking her feet.
But all foxes are evil.
So keep your eyes open.
Why are we trusting you, narrator?
How many foxes have you met?
You assume all of them are evil.
Just look at this nice little stroll.
And there's like a...
Hey doll, find the doll number one.
Everything begins with the song of a jack...jack doll.
She's so like, okay, about everything.
Is this Blair Witch?
Nothing?
Yeah, misfortune, yeah.
Me and misfortune are of the same...oh!
It's Benjamin!
What do you mean attack it?
He doesn't even notice I'm here.
Hi Benjamin!
He's like...
No!
He hates us!
He hates us.
Cave sounds exciting.
Can I finish this?
Sprinkle glitter to the...to the...
cult circle.
She didn't finish it.
Oh, we finished it for him.
Were we supposed to finish that?
It's the moose!
He keeps the sea bears out.
Hey, get out of my way.
Out of my way.
Be careful of your head, misfortune.
Be careful of your head.
Sparkle!
To the...to the...to the dancing outline.
Warning signs are for losers.
These rules are meant to be broken, huh?
Nah, lame, lame cave.
I didn't believe in ghosts until I found my Yoshi.
What does this sign mean?
Oh, sparkles!
I'll sparkle it.
Oh, stay in the forest.
Hold on.
I want to sparkle it.
I want to sparkle it first.
Oh, it didn't do anything.
I thought it would work.
I'd be stuck with so much choice paralysis.
Misfortune is...she's a girl who knows what she wants.
She's a little girly who...
Actually, she just kind of blindly follows anything he says.
Alright, time to enter the cave, I guess.
Magic!
A little lady...oh, yeah, sorry, my bad.
She's a little lady.
Echo!
Okay.
You can at least humor us, narrator.
Come on.
Oh my god, we almost got run over by a rat!
What the hell?
We need to have stop lights in this dang cave.
What are you...Mr.
Narrator!
Mr. Narrator!
Oh my god.
What do you want me to do?
End the violence between the hamsters?
No, let's just see what happens.
Let's just see what happens.
It's not our drama.
Fight!
Oh damn, he took him out!
Now he's dragging him inside.
They went inside to party.
It looks like someone spilled their ketchup.
Someone had a big burger in there.
Kanna!
Thanks for the raid!
My name is Mint Phantom.
Today we are playing Little Misfortune.
It's a bit of a weird game.
Is there money in here?
Let's take the money and the gun.
Take the gun, Misfortune!
Oh Misfortune.
Oh no!
Misfortune!
I don't think she was supposed to take the mints.
Ducky!
Thanks for the 5 gift card!
Notorious Banshee, thanks for the gift card!
Oh, there's a puppy and her friends.
Yes!
Oh, the puppy is like, yeah, let's go!
Oh my gosh.
Oh no, not the crows!
Croaky!
This is me too whenever I say croaky.
You guys, mints.
Not even once.
What do we do with the purse?
I guess we just take it.
Hey Mr. Hamster, can I get in?
Little lady.
How would we even get in?
I don't think even crawling we would be able to make it through there.
Sir Streak, thanks for the 5 gift card!
What does this mean?
Also, I'm not that important.
What?
This guy is that important?
Huh?
This guy?
This guy right here is that important?
Okay.
Sure.
But I'm not that...
I don't... It's also... It's... It's like...
Not even like a club club.
It's like... How is this an exclusive club?
Hijack the cars?
Yeah, let's take the cars.
Try princess!
Thanks for the gift card!
So cute!
Oh my goodness.
What are these guys doing?
Nah, they're just adorable little hamsters.
These guys, they're gonna have little more hamster...
Oh my gosh, when I was a kid, we had hamsters.
And...
They kept multiplying.
They escaped from the cages once, and then we couldn't find them.
And then they kept having babies in the walls.
And...
Then, I don't know what happened.
I think it got buried in the back.
Somehow they died.
I don't know.
I was a kid, so...
I probably wasn't told the whole truth.
I just remember where at least one of them was buried in the backyard.
They were in your walls.
I don't know where they were.
They were just lost.
And like sometimes under the beds and stuff, we would find little hamster poops.
Trying to find all the hamsters.
AGSMG, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I mean, would you want them to let a little lady inside that kind of club?
Yeah, we are a lady.
We are too ladylike.
We are too...
We go to classier clubs than this.
You know what?
Let's get out of here.
What's this?
How do you recognize...
How do you know that narrator?
He is going on a robbing spree.
He is mugging everyone.
Let's help our grandma.
Oh, my bad.
Hold on.
But watch out for the mints.
Hamster crime spree.
Oh my god!
VIP!
Wow, very important hamster.
I'm same.
How is that the only way out?
What is this though?
This area is so mysterious.
What are these?
Some sort of export?
Excuse me, I'm very important now.
Excuse me, I'm a very VIP.
Here is my ticket.
Let me in!
Oh my god.
We are in the real party!
How did they get so big?
In a hamster club?
Ok.
I'm not gonna get caught...
Not copyright.
I'm not gonna get struck though, right?
It's fine.
Probably.
I'm not playing honey pop or anything.
Look at her dance.
Excuse me.
Yummy.
Ribbon maybe?
Anybody else?
Glitter for you!
I have to get...I can't get past him.
Oh my god!
I don't...what does that mean?
Huh?
Very important poltergeist.
Oh my gosh, we gotta actually play.
Alright, let's go.
The face is so funny.
It's SSR!
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Oh, no!
My finger slipped.
It's...
Wait, why is it SSR?
Oh, stone revolution.
That's what I was thinking.
Shake that booty!
Do, do, do.
Oh my god.
Oh she loves me!
How much longer is this?
What is this?
She
loves us!
Oh my gosh, Stoney is so good.
Score high in the club.
I think I scored high.
I know, I almost had a full combo.
My finger slipped.
Did that work?
OK.
Maybe he doesn't need anymore glitter.
This club owns...
Wait, is this the guy from the IT crowd or whatever?
Wait.
Is that the White Rama?
Oh wait, anything else in here?
Glitter for the club!
OK, let's leave.
It looks exactly like him, right?
A missing child.
Me?
I missed one!
Where?
When?
I missed one.
Oh my god.
How did she do that?
Thank you.
Oh it's an interaction.
OK.
Don't scare me.
We gotta get all the glitters, you guys.
But if I'm missing interactions, I'm scared I'll miss the glitters too.
I can't miss anything.
Call 112.
Maybe, yeah.
Oh, OK!
You can!
Is she the mask that lady was wearing?
Alright, maybe we can glitter the missing poster.
Sparkle 50 times!
Is that her?
It reminds me of that game where everybody wears masks or whatever.
Or like when you take the medicine to be happy.
A unicycle.
Phantasmagoria.
Be happy if you...yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's so awesome!
Oh my gosh, we have to go.
We have to go to the spooky fair.
The horror fair.
Benjamin!
She's so forward.
Yeah, narrator, stay in your lane.
She can't have been to that anyway.
You, Child-Ren?
Hide your Child-Ren.
Hide.
Hide your...
Benjamin.
Oh my god!
This is the thing we've been seeing.
We have Hannibal Lecter just casually walking by.
Eh, okay.
He's trying his best on Judge Benji's rising.
I'm not.
He's a little fox.
He's doing his best, you know?
Let's see what else we got in here.
A train?
What's this?
Not in here?
Okay.
We're not taking the train.
We're running, running, running by.
Oh my god!
Miss Fortune!
Yeah!
Creepy people walking by.
Why does everybody have these masks on?
Being able to read the Swedish throws me off.
It's because she's not eating enough.
Yeah!
Let's try the sparkle.
Let's go find the prize and make mommy proud.
Okay.
We're at the park, baby.
What's around here?
Happiness to the sign!
What's this say?
Okay.
Happiness to the trash!
What's the bench say?
Probably a lot of bad words.
Yeah,
let's read them.
That's deep, you know?
Where are they hanging from?
Well, I don't see the cat.
Balls hanging too low.
I see Fran Bow.
Eat fruits and veggies.
Balls hanging too low.
Kind of is like...
You know, it's like life.
They're hanging too low and it's just hard to pick them up.
And move.
I think.
It's really deep, yeah.
Fran Bow is their other game, right?
Why does the bird look like someone's dad?
My fish friend forever!
This is my FFF.
No, don't feel like you have to give up your fish misfortune.
Does this seagull even deserve the fish?
I don't think he deserves Rodrigo.
We've had Rodrigo this whole time.
Rodrigo is ours.
I'm gonna keep my friend.
He's my FFF.
Exactly.
Yeah, well you were the one trying to convince me to get rid of him, narrator.
Hopefully that didn't result in a missed sparkle opportunity.
Yes!
Yes, the royal horse!
Royal horse you say?
I'm a little princess, you know.
A little princess, a little lady.
Look at me.
I'm on the horse.
Ay, horse is stupid.
That's fortunate I think you need to hold on when you ride the horse.
That was unfortunate.
Are you alright?
I'm okay.
I'm worried because I'm such a little lady.
You are really tiny and you could break.
I broke my arm once.
So you know what I mean.
I've never broken any ectoplasm before.
Which is weird.
You wouldn't think it could break, you know.
Check out that bag.
Just go, Miss Fortune.
You don't want to get involved with ducks.
You don't like ducks?
You don't like foxes?
What's wrong with you?
And look, he's carrying a boombox.
This could be my opportunity to finally dance for real.
Would you like to show me some of your dance moves?
What's that?
Wait, show off my dance moves?
I kind of want to see the duck dance though.
I kind of want to see the duck dance.
One chill duck.
Let's watch him duck.
I mean, not duck.
Let's see him dance.
I haven't practiced for a while.
No, you've got good moves.
Let's watch him go though.
Don't kick me.
You're getting really close.
Ow!
This guy sucks.
Wait, he's really close again.
Miss Fortune, back up!
Miss Fortune...
She's still dancing though.
Normal?
Sparkle to the duck.
This guy sucks.
I thought he was chill, but he's not chill like that at all.
Here's another thing we can ride.
Do you think she'll hold on though?
I don't think she's going to hold on you guys.
No!
Miss Fortune!
She can't stop eating glitter and dirt.
Mysterious plushie number two!
I like how she giggled after naked.
I have a caramel apple!
I forgot to eat it.
I'm going to eat it after this stream.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, Mr. Narrator.
He put it upside down.
Really?
Glitter to the signs!
I don't like the thought of that.
The pet cemetery.
But we didn't get to go to Phasmagoria.
Yes.
Sure.
I'm pretty good at answering questions.
What's that?
Be honest, child.
Be honest.
Hell yeah!
I have a toy.
I think I once stole a toy from a friend when I was a kid too.
Yeah, I've stolen stuff.
Whatever.
I stole my friend's Swiss army knife once.
I felt so bad, I buried it in the yard and never told him.
Oh my gosh!
Some treasure hunter is going to go find that.
With this little metal detector.
Am I happy right now?
I would be happier if it was tomorrow in my debut!
I stole someone's heart but I returned it.
Wow.
Why did you return it though?
I would never tell a lie.
What if I said no?
Let's just say no.
The last question.
Do I feel loved?
Chat, do you feel loved?
Do you feel loved?
No.
How about when I start the stream late?
You hate us.
She hates us!
I don't know.
I don't think she feels loved.
Red eyes, black dragon, welcome to Bamboo Chef.
Thank you!
She hates us!
Wow.
Thank you for your honesty.
What are you going to do with those answers?
More missing children.
It's the same girl and then another kid.
How do you read this?
Oh my god!
Ok,
you promise?
You promise dear reader?
Sparkles!
Glitter to the missing children!
Eternal happiness.
I have to dig in a grave?
That's weird.
Yikes forever.
Goldfish.
What shovel?
Don't drop it on my head!
Ok, summoning it from hell?
Demon shovel.
With the way this game is, I literally thought I was going to drop from the sky.
Also, some people said...
The hat.
Do you think it's Hiro?
Hiro the ghost?
Glitter to the watering can.
Is it this one?
I don't think so.
Free shovel.
Thanks Satan!
This grave feels very haunted mansion, right?
What about this one?
Ok, let's see.
Little Lulu.
The first pug to ever strangle a man.
The first, but not the last.
No, I don't think it's this one.
Running table!
I don't think this is the fish.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I don't think a pug is a fish.
Do you think the pug would be the first to strangle himself?
He's got no way to breathe.
Poor pugs.
Stephanie Quinn, writer of the erotic novel, Confessions of a Cat.
Erotic novel?
Talk about crazy!
I'm gonna search that later.
Nah, this is obviously a cat.
Obviously a cat.
Sparkle to the erotic novelist.
Sparkle to the murder pug.
What's this one?
This one has a candle lit.
It says, Poe died doing what he loved.
Eating poo.
Yikes, forever.
Hi Poco!
Welcome to membership!
How does she know what an erotic novel is?
Miss Fortune knows a lot of things, you know.
Sometimes fish do eat their own poo.
Nah, I don't think so.
But I have a sneaking suspicion.
Glitter for the poo eater.
This one, ok.
I have two more.
These ones are small, so... What's this one?
Let's see.
Roger the magpie.
Never saw that window coming.
I don't get it.
Oh, no, no, no.
No.
Nah, I don't think so.
I'll keep looking.
Do you think I can actually dig these up?
And sparkle them, I wonder.
I wonder if I should try.
Hold on, I am going to try.
Let's see.
Roger the magpie.
Never saw that window coming.
I don't get it.
Let's dig all of them up.
Time to become a professional grave digger.
Ah, no prize in here.
Maybe not.
I thought we would at least get some bones or something, you know.
It says...
Yeah, hold on.
Yikes forever.
Ok.
Dig it up.
Ah, no prize in here.
Just a bunch of little bones.
Ok.
That's just a bunch of little bones.
Maybe it's not worth digging all of them up.
Ok.
Must be the last one.
Whose sad little grave is this one?
I don't even get a headstone.
One more at the far end.
Ok, let's try it.
Oh, I thought you meant the one...
Too little information.
I thought you meant go and try the one over all the way here.
You know what?
Let's try it.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yes.
There we go.
Dig it up!
We've got this narrator.
Stop backseating.
God!
Ok, now I'm gonna dig up all of them because he annoyed me.
I'm gonna dig up all of them because he annoyed me.
Yeah!
Go!
Nothing.
Alright.
What if the erotic novel is in here?
What if we get the book?
And what a prize it would have been.
I just caused a mess of this cemetery, but you know.
Dig this grave?
Yes.
Am I reading anything new?
No.
Not right now.
Giving my brain a rest.
Oh, I got an achievement.
Dig all the graves.
I was called Tomb Lady.
I actually got an achievement for digging up all the graves.
Eternal happiness!
Eternal happiness.
Signed, Benjamin.
Benjamin?
No, he wouldn't.
He didn't.
My eternal happiness.
No!
No, he didn't.
What a disappointment.
I really wanted to surprise mommy with this.
What should I do now?
I think we were so close guys.
Yes, let's do that.
Such a letdown.
Look, there he is.
I meant to sparkle!
Did you steal my eternal happiness?
Not cool.
He is just here at the scene of the crime.
Hello Benjamin.
Give me back my happiness.
Run after him.
We can't let the fox get away again.
Okay.
He stole your prize.
Benjamin really disappointed me.
Oh my gosh, that's the worst.
She's not angry.
She's disappointed.
Rainbow eternal happiness!
And he left a prize.
Find the doll 3.
When unloved children in darkness search for what they have lost, for why they're in pain.
Children in pain?
Did you find something, Miss Fortune?
No, you're imagining things.
Yeah, shut up narrator, you stupid.
Let's go after Benjamin.
I think someone set Benjamin up.
Maybe.
He seems like a good guy.
In case we see the fox, they know how to hide.
Alright.
Spooky.
What's this?
What the...
It's a door to... It's a door?
Shake out this stone.
It's different from regular stones, I'm telling you.
I think you're right.
What's this?
The game of death is what feeds the shadows of the beyond.
What does this mean?
That looks like nonsense to me, Miss Fortune.
Huh, really?
Maybe there's some more nonsense around.
The game of death is what feeds the shadows...
Are we not playing...
Huh, really?
Are we not playing a game right now?
Oh, this piece is loose.
I'll take it for me.
Maybe it works somewhere else.
Let's take it.
Nice.
Oh, maybe not nice.
Glitter to the eyeless statue.
Okay.
I don't know.
Maybe we should sparkle it.
Now it's safe.
He's jealous.
No.
She's always thinking of her mom.
Oh my gosh,
this doesn't look safe at all.
There's a lot of fire around a bunch of dry straw.
Mr. Voice?
What's this?
We actually found a needle.
Wait, you can probably find it again.
Glitter to the needle in the haystack.
Fox repellent.
Best 10 out of 10.
Fox repellent?
I can't deny the bottle's sweet style.
I'll take it.
Oh, okay.
I guess we want that.
Oh, we had to take it.
There's nothing else.
Oh, we couldn't even...oh, what's this?
It looks like there's somebody else behind us.
Hello?
Creepy.
Benjamin!
Oh, he just went...going to the bathroom.
It's a litter box.
Benjamin's like, um...
Use the fox repellent?
No, we need to ask him for the journal of happiness.
Benjamin's so rude!
I should have used the repellent on him.
Benjamin!
I won't...
I won't be nice to you next time.
Narrator?
Where am I?
What happened?
A dangerous fox attacked you.
He actually did though.
He actually kind of did attack you.
See?
I told you.
That fox is evil.
Yeah.
Maybe I should listen to you.
We still need to find the fox and take back the eternal happiness.
Maybe we could find out where he lives.
Yes.
Give me a minute to figure this out and I'll get back to you.
Okay.
I'll just hang around.
Nah, we're just chilling.
Whenever I play games like this where it's like...
Everyone in the world is...
Is bad and the world is bad and everyone's just a total asshole.
I'm just like... About the game devs, I'm always like...
Who hurt you?
Let's just, uh...
Let's put glitter on my throw up.
For anybody who sees my throw up on the ground.
Oh, a newspaper.
Open field...
Let it...
Open field is on fire!
Oh no.
Local artist GM retires after incident.
My son is missing.
Bird invasion.
We didn't win, but we had fun.
Let's see what's new.
Glitter for the newspaper.
What's this?
Oh my gosh!
It's that weird ass bird!
I'm just gonna go ask another fox.
To the zoo.
It's like really far away.
A few birds.
Oh, but I have no money.
For a bus ticket.
There's glitter to the trash.
Oh my gosh, Ikea.
Glitter to Ikea trash.
Is there any...
Nothing to view.
Okay.
Open fields centrum gallerian.
You're just a voice in my head.
Just a voice?
Prove it.
Do you have any plans to make voice packs?
Whatever you say, Mr. Voice.
Maybe.
Yes, I do.
One moment, we're fixing our stuff.
I would like to make voice packs though, yeah.
There.
Did you see?
I'm not just a voice in your head, Miss Fortune.
A what?
Did you see?
I'm sorry, I had a shoelace problem.
Let's just keep going.
She literally told you that she was tying her shoe.
You can't get mad at her.
You dummy.
She literally said, oh, hold on, let me tie my shoe.
Hey, you look familiar.
What?
All missing children.
Miss Sims.
Wait a minute, is that Daniela Bambini?
Bambini?
You know this child?
Yes, from school.
She told our teacher to shove the homework at his butt.
She's very Italian, you know.
She probably ran away from home.
She will turn up soon.
You think so?
Yes.
Okay.
It looks like she's got a third eye.
Bambini.
She's kind of awesome.
Sparkles for the old man.
Oh, what's this?
Those people in the picture look so happy drinking their juice.
Yummy juice.
You can't go in there.
She brings me here all the time.
It's really boring.
Sometimes she sends me to buy cigarettes while she hacks strangers by the dumpster.
Is that so?
She's just hugging them.
Sometimes it's probably like a...
Oh my god!
Take it!
Steal it!
Steal the wallet!
Yeah!
Take the wallet.
We're taking it.
Steal.
There's just a picture inside.
It must be his kid.
What do you think?
Sure.
Why not?
I knew it.
I'm such a clever little lady.
She's making such intelligent deductions.
Okay, that guy scared me when he turned around so fast.
What's in here?
One time mommy took me here and forgot me.
I got to play inside all night until a security man found me.
He thought I was a raccoon.
That's like every kid's dream though.
Except for me crying a lot, but it was fun.
It's kind of every kid's dream though, right?
To like stay in like a mall or a...
Raccoon!
And like just kind of explore places like that.
Happy face.
Oh, this is where people get those weird-ass masks.
I want to do it once.
I know, right?
I feel like they should create like a...
Like a...
Simulation of what, you know?
Like a kid's play place.
Like this is what it would be like if you got locked in a grocery store at night.
And you can like hide in the...
In the clothes.
Oh my gosh, and then if the...
If some of the...
What's it called?
The people...
The people who like work there dressed up as security and walked around with like flashlights and you had to avoid them.
Oh my gosh, I'm just creating...
I'm creating Metal Gear.
That would be so fun though, actually.
Who's Casey?
Oh gosh.
Where's all these kids?
Everybody's going missing.
Everybody's going missing!
Oh my God.
Oh my gosh.
This is a lot of children.
I don't know, narrate.
I don't know.
Mysterious.
Glitter to the missing children post.
This is the kid we just saw in the picture.
There you go.
This looks like the other lady we saw, but this is...
Wait.
In the picture, are both missing?
I got the little notes and everything.
Mystery for the Scooby gang.
It's just a little concerning, but yeah, it's no big deal.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I can read.
What's this?
Ping pong.
Help me.
Oh, okay.
We're already meeting his family.
Oh yeah, sorry.
We don't like Benjamin right now.
Yeah.
Screw Benjamin.
Yikes forever.
What are we doing here?
Wow.
Great.
I think about it.
Maybe you'll meet a bestie kid.
You sound old.
Okay.
Are you like 20?
That's like, I think that's the most childlike response she's given this whole game.
You know, whenever kids are just like, are you old?
You're probably like 20 or something.
It's like always what they say.
Yeah, rhymes with chicken's road.
Misfortune!
She's so like, you're no fun.
Rude, rude.
Sprinkled with glitter.
Okay, I think we gotta wait for the bus now.
Cool.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, we're just gonna chill.
I wanna take a nap.
I'll sit.
I'm a bit tired from all the walking, you know.
I can imagine.
You have very small feet.
Yes, I'm a little lady.
That's what I am.
She's so cute.
Check those old ladies out.
They're a little scary, don't you think?
Yeah, they need new masks.
I've seen worse.
Really?
Yes.
You know, my mommy also uses the same mask.
She likes to hide her smile and tears behind it.
Would you like to have a mask like that?
Maybe.
I don't know.
You follow your own road, Misfortune.
You don't have to follow, you don't have to conform.
See, the bus driver didn't have a mask on.
Free of harm.
Free of regrets.
It's OK.
Hiro is keeping me company.
Hiro is here?
He is my friend from Japan.
Yeah, were you not paying attention before, narrator?
Where is Kiri?
I love cows.
Oh my gosh, cute!
The zoo?
OK, great.
I have no commentary for that moment.
In fact, I don't even want to.
Yikes, forever.
That's a good...
What?
And she got some free food.
No titties yet.
Yeah, maybe not that method.
Diversion?
What does diversion mean?
OK.
Alright, we are going to do an ultra cool dance or something.
What's this?
Why?
Don't give her false hope.
There is more of them here too.
Oh my gosh, I just almost exited out of the game.
Alright, diversion time!
Glitter!
Glitter to the missing children.
Let's see what's in the trash.
No, maybe we shouldn't dig through the trash.
Oh my gosh, we have to go to Phantasmagoria.
Phantasmagoria.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, this guy has no memory.
The narrator sucks.
You said we would go.
Like a stony?
We tell a lie or break the window.
Vandalism?
Or lying?
But then would we have to lose Stony?
We got a wild hair.
Break the window!
Oh, I can use the rude stone.
Interesting.
Bye Stony!
Grab him!
Ok, nice, nice.
Go, go, go!
It wasn't me, it wasn't me.
We got him back guys, it's fine.
Isn't this wonderful?
We'll get to see so many caged animals.
Why are you putting the emphasis on the cage?
By the way, you did a great job not getting caught by the vendor.
Oh, thank you.
Ah, thank you.
But now, we should find out where the wolf exhibited.
I think I should have maybe...
Sparkled the thing.
Uh oh.
Remember, he knows where the fox lives.
Hopefully I didn't need to sparkle the window to prepare it.
This bird invasion is crazy.
Oh my god.
What is happening here?
It's a bird!
What did he say?
What's going on?
It's fortunate.
Where did you learn such language?
It's the pirate parrot.
Num-Num Parrot.
Wildly spread around the planet.
This kind of parrot lives across the entire world.
They talk much, but they say very little.
They usually work together with human pirates.
Oh, natural born thieves!
Founders of the liberation front.
It says, the Num-Num Parrot.
This kind of parrot lives across the entire world.
They talk much, but they say very little.
They usually work together with human pirates.
Natural born thieves.
Founders of the liberation front.
Mean birdy Num-Num.
Glitter bird.
What about this guy?
He's very wise.
This bird seems pretty smart.
You're great.
Welcome to the bamboo ship.
Thank you.
Ignore this guy.
Oh my god, it's the bird bird.
It says, Owl Delicious.
Owl Delicious.
Owls normally hang near libraries, bookstores and coffee shops.
Although they seem incredibly smart, their huge self-centered lifestyle drives them to gather useless information.
They live off attention.
Bunny bird.
He's like a hipster bird.
Owl Delicious.
Even more delicious now with some sparkles.
Oh my god, it's him.
It's the bird.
It's the mysterious... Oh my god, it's the fuck delicious.
It says, Pachydilios Dishidio.
These birds multiply at a very high rate with different partners, leaving behind dysfunctional offspring.
They don't care about anything as long as they are occupied by mindless entertainment.
Another Vtuber fans.
40 to 70 years.
Holy moly.
Don't flip me off please.
Somehow I feel offended by that bird.
It doesn't know what it's doing.
Food.
A snack.
Steal the bird seed?
Yeah.
I'm a crime lord now.
Can I feed them for real?
Oh I can!
Thrill!
She's so...
She's so aggressive.
It's like when a kid has a...
has a cat, you know?
And they are just so aggressively petting the animal.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe it needs more glitter.
I think this bird has enough food.
Oh I got a feed the birds achievement.
Lucky us.
She's a cute menace.
She really is.
She's got a lot going on, doesn't she?
The wolf area.
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
There is a moose.
There is a brown bear.
I don't think the wolf and the polar bear should be together.
In fact, I don't think the polar bear is in the right temperature at all.
Oh my gosh.
The restaurant.
Hi ghost lady.
Ice cupboard!
Where is the lion?
Pet the wolfy.
Ok, we are running.
It's gonna close.
Feeling annoyed?
By what?
Wait, what do you mean hormones?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
So true.
Why are you telling her all of this?
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
What do you mean the hormones?
Because why are the hormones making her annoyed?
Still don't.
Yikes forever.
She doesn't want a bad boy.
Shut up.
Let her dream.
Good Benjamin.
Where was he anyway?
Yeah.
You tell him.
What?
I'm just looking.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
That is not a good exhibit for a polar bear.
Meet Popsicle.
Oh my.
Sneaking mission.
How did I lie?
We've been watching chat.
You're gonna believe this hack of a narrator.
Let's do this.
For real.
And if not just blind...
What?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't tell mommy.
Yeah, kill him from behind.
Oh my gosh, it's a crow.
I mean you could still... I was gonna say throw the glitter in the face, but you know...
Wait, I wanna see Popsicle.
Look, the bear in the picture is sucking a Popsicle.
It looks like it's strawberry flavored.
Or it's black flavored.
Oh, the bird is looking.
Go Miss Fortune!
Go!
Oh my God.
OK Is that polar bear OK?
Come on, I'm waiting for him to... OK, there we go.
And...
Little Miss Fortune, please.
Miss Fortune!
Sneak past the janitor.
Ninja lady.
The wolf.
We're getting pretty close.
I'll have... You know ghosts are very real.
Yeah, you have two right here.
We're ghosts, we're ghosts.
We can use the stone.
Oh,
demonic.
What?
Why does anyone pay attention to things, huh?
Huh, Mr. Narrator?
Huh?
Oh, the wolf.
My ninja.
Why you gotta make fun of her, huh?
What?
Come on.
Don't be like that.
It wasn't a competition.
Ninja.
Got it.
Meet the wolf, maybe pet it, and get Benjamin's address.
Like a ninja.
Wait, hold on.
So then, just one second.
A big, bad wolf.
You think it's a wolf?
What about red hats, little girls?
Red-hatted little girls.
He's already in jail.
He's already in the cage.
What else do you want from him?
Why can't I click on that?
Why does he have it?
That's awfully convenient.
Why must that be with...
I don't know.
She still loves him.
She still believes him.
I don't know anyone called Yanni.
Who's that?
Yanni?
What do you mean Johnny?
Are you sure about that?
Johnny mentioned...
He really is Metal Gear.
Oh my God, Sniper Wolf?
Johnny?
Sneaking past the guards?
Guys...
It's not me.
It's the rest of the world, OK?
Ninja?
Guys...
Gray Fox?
You're that ninja!
Guys, it's all coming together for real.
OK, there's a lot going on in here.
Let's see what we got.
What's this?
Fancy!
It's a doll!
Is there a key in here?
Another doll.
A gift?
A gift or...
A prize?
Nothing!
Gosh, he's so nosy, guys.
Fancy!
Oh, we don't know yet.
We don't know.
Safety rules for handling the big bad wolf.
About your life?
So if I don't have regrets, the wolf will let me pet it?
Yeah, that's girl math.
That's some real girl math thinking right there, Miss Lady.
Eventually all things lead back to that wacky adventure at Shadow Moses.
Yeah, exactly.
We found...
I found a paper with some numbers on it.
8, 9, 4, 5.
Oh wait, 6.
8, 6, 4, 5.
What's in the boots?
And that's just what they'll do.
Focus.
Gosh, let her have a little time to sing and dance.
That's a 9.
You guys!
You guys.
Hold on.
How do I get to the inventory?
How do I look at my inventory?
How do I look...Oh that...It literally...
You guys, it literally wrote 6...
What do you mean bit?
What are you talking about?
That was definitely a 9.
It literally said 6.
It said...It had an arrow pointed to it and said 6.
What are you talking about?
How do I see my...How do I see my...
My inventory?
I...Tab...
How...How...Options...
How do I see?
Oh my gosh.
My bad.
I clicked the main menu.
Extras.
Art Gallery.
Dang it.
No.
This is cool though.
I didn't realize the background would change.
Hold on, maybe we'll see it again here.
Oh I gotta get the doll again.
OK, look, look.
Paper.
Look.
8.
And then it's a 9.
Obviously.
But it has an arrow.
It says 6 right there with an arrow pointed at it.
I'm not crazy.
You guys can't read.
8, 6, 4, 5.
Yeah chat, you're the dummies now.
You're the idiots today.
Get told by the VTuber.
A VTuber corrected you.
You should feel so embarrassed right now.
You probably feel so stupid right now.
You probably are just like, oh my gosh, wow, the VTuber was correct.
Wait, I tried to backseat the VTuber and I was wrong?
Sacre bleu, that cannot be.
There is no way that I was wrong.
The VTuber is supposed to be clueless.
The streamer is supposed to always be incorrect and I, the chatter, am always supposed to be the one that has the smarter advantage.
Because I am the one paying attention when the VTuber is not paying attention to the game.
But today, the VTuber was able to correctly say something that I had missed?
This cannot be happening.
No, the VTuber is supposed to be the idiot and I'm supposed to watch the VTuber and say, Stupid VTuber, I will correct you in the chat and I will say the correct answer when you do not see the thing that I saw immediately.
When you do not see the thing that you should have seen, but that's okay.
I saw it because I am the smarter person and I feel good about myself because I'm watching the idiot VTuber.
But today I got schooled by a VTuber?
Oh my gosh.
I can't watch this VTuber anymore.
This VTuber sucks and they made me feel like an idiot.
Actually this VTuber is terrible.
I hope this VTuber loses all their subscribers.
I hope this VTuber feels terrible about themselves because they made me feel bad.
I'm now an auntie to this VTuber.
What's going on with the computer?
Let's try it.
Our bad boss.
Your big head was in the way of the note.
No it wasn't!
I know it wasn't.
So 8, 9...let's see actually if it works.
8, 6...oh wait.
8, 6, 4, 5...
5, 4, 6, 8?
We both...we are both wrong.
Oh my gosh, a private chat.
Hi, you there?
Yeah, I was in the toilet.
Hello?
OMGWTF?
No need that info.
Oh my gosh, this computer is great.
Please get your monitor fixed.
How's that ear infection?
It's fine.
Super.
We can talk some other time.
Take care.
Rocket ship.
I forgot to tell you about...
There's a spare key inside the safe.
If you need it sometime.
It opens all the doors and cages.
Oh.
Wow, that's handy.
Nobody wins.
We all suck.
Yeah!
2, 7, 5, 8, 1.
Everybody remember that.
Okay.
I don't think I need it at the moment.
I already have one, but thanks.
Today.
Feeling much better today.
How's the bear doing?
It keeps sucking that popsicle.
Is that normal?
I'm not sure.
But I like to watch.
LOL.
Gotta go fix Calvin's cage.
Wait, what was it?
2...
Wait.
2, 7, 5, 8, 1.
Yeah.
2...
7...
5...
8...
1.
Got it.
Stop giving wrong numbers!
Take the key.
Yes, I'm the best little ninja lady.
I got the key.
You're so good at this game.
Miss Fortune.
Thank you.
Oh, the tea.
Do I smell tea?
Fancy!
Anything else?
What was in the bucket?
Any keys inside the bucket?
No.
We already got the keys, so let's head out.
Fancy!
And let's go to...
Not Calvin.
This guy's cage.
Gah!
Is that why you guys were saying gah earlier?
I think we just let the wolf free.
Excuse me.
Uh...
Oh my god.
We're having a moment.
He's sniffing us.
Cleverly done.
You gotta let him sniff your hand.
No!
The wolf is free though.
I'm gonna take it.
Now there's a bird invasion.
Actually, it's good.
We set the wolf free and he'll take care of the bird invasion.
Alright.
My evil cousin's address.
Fox.
Wait, I can't read.
Skogstigen.
Nice.
Doxt.
Alright, sweet.
Phantasmagoria!
Yippee!
I once pet a wolf and ever since then I can cosplay Venomstake so much better.
It's starting to get dark.
Skogstigen is Forest Road.
Have you ever heard this question before?
I don't think so.
Wait, which question?
Which one?
Yes, technically.
Yeah, I've lied to a friend.
All the time!
We're bad misfortune now.
Oh, seeing someone?
We saw dead people, but did we see anybody die?
We've seen dead people, but I don't think we've seen anyone die.
Oh, the puppy!
Oh yeah, you're right.
We saw the puppy.
There's so many missing children posters.
You're welcome.
Phantasmagoria!
We saw the hamster, but that was inside.
We only saw the ketchup after.
Oh my gosh!
Tuck's hair behind here.
Hi handsome!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, I didn't think that...
Someone so...
He's just so tall and spooky.
And I didn't think that...
Guys, how do I look?
Is there anything in my teeth?
Does my hair look okay?
Do you think if I talk to them they'll be like...
Okay, I'm gonna go shoot my shot.
Oh my gosh!
Miss Fortune, please!
Why couldn't you do that with the zoo?
Don't play with my feelings.
It can't be a ticket.
Only you had your 3.0.
I know.
He's gonna be like your doll.
I need a new shiny Mento.
Okay, come back tomorrow.
And I'll be beautiful!
What's this?
Creepy!
Cute!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, we can...we can shine this.
Let's grab our ticket.
Sweet and spooky!
Oh my gosh, that's just like me!
You're welcome, Miss Fortune.
I didn't thank you.
I thanked the universe.
Not you though.
Wait!
We can talk to him.
A ghost?
Damn, that's creepy.
Miss Fortune, please, mind your language.
But I got scared.
It's totally understandable.
That's no excuse.
Damn shame.
It's okay, I'm used to being called creepy.
It's like...
The best compliment ever.
Thank you, Miss Fortune.
My soul is so happy.
Thank you.
I love being creepy.
A creepy clown?
That's creepy.
Okay, but creepy clowns suck.
Creepy ghosts...
What's this?
Balloons.
Do you think she loves balloons?
She's trying to get another thing out of the area.
Okay.
The balloon just disappeared.
Creepy clowns...
Hot dogs!
Oh my gosh.
I added...
That reminds me.
I added a new Streamlabs donation sound.
Glitter?
I already did the glitter, you guys.
I already did it.
Arm corve.
My favorite.
Yeah.
And now?
Did you now?
Thanks for the donation.
Well, thanks for the hot dogs.
Rolling for new Minto sound.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
And it's even a fox!
I screamed.
That got me actually.
I didn't expect to get jump scared in this game.
So it actually got me so much.
Rolling for Minto.
Looks like normal Benjamin to me.
Happy Benjamin!
Well, if I say Chu gacha I'll get the other sound.
Oh my gosh.
Notif sound gacha.
It's kinda quiet though.
This will be the new Dono sound.
Pumpkin head!
Oh my gosh.
All these tall ass people.
What's wrong with having a pumpkin head?
But my head is not very pumpkin like.
It's delightful.
Miss Fortune, don't eat the candy off the ground.
Ew!
Are you really gonna eat some of it?
Ah, YOLO.
Yeah, you know what?
Wait, what's going on?
Maybe I shouldn't have eaten the candy.
No hot dog.
Ah, no hot dog.
Oh my god!
No, we are having a nightmare this time.
I've never seen... Wait, I don't think I...
Oh, her dad is a straw man.
Her dad is on fire!
And we are eating...
Oh no, her poor heart.
Oh, Miss Fortune.
No!
What kind of candy was this?
Oh gosh.
I think it maybe was like the disease on the ground, not the candy.
I think we are...
Some happiness to Miss Fortune.
See, we are fine guys.
That's just some...
Can we go to the horror house?
Ok, there was the carousel, there was the horror house.
What else is there?
Maybe you should try stilts too.
You might reach Miss Fortune.
You should use stilts so you can reach the matters.
What the hell?
Why am I taking strides like this?
Wait, what is this one?
Ok, so I think it's just...
Oh wait, can we get the hot dog?
Or no?
No, we can't.
Thanks for the raid.
Thank you!
Welcome, welcome.
We are like in the middle of this creepy, silly game but...
Hello, welcome!
Thanks for the 5 gift card!
We are about to go in a haunted house!
Oh my gosh, I hope it's really spooky.
Wait, where did the door go?
Oh there it is.
Haunted house!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Alright then, have a pleasant ride.
Emily, hello!
Thank you for the hot dog!
Oh no, I think I bought too many hot dogs.
Spooky!
Oh my gosh, it's like a... Oh my gosh, this is my dream.
A haunted roller coaster?
Don't drink that.
Aliens!
You are pretty good.
Wow!
Maybe she didn't like it.
Don't throw up.
Actually, maybe it would be good if she did puke and get the candy out of her system.
Take a deep breath and you will soon feel better.
Good, good.
Now, let's go find the hot dog.
You know, actually, how you can stop yourself from throwing up is by humming.
Whenever I feel like I'm going to throw up, I just start humming.
It actually helps because you can't throw up and hum at the same time.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
So I just go like...
Yeah, it's actually like so easy.
My life hack or after life...
Kira!
My after life hack.
Kira the ghost!
Time to go.
I like the way she gallops away.
Can I play one?
Yeah!
Just swallow it.
Hot dog!
Trying for Arona.
Oh, it is kind of like the Arona hot dog.
Ok, we got Massacre.
Danger now with real bullets.
Whack-a-Fox.
Fortuna.
Advance.
Happy Halloween.
Spoopy ghost.
Thanks, Loli!
Rewards?
Wait, we can get another stone.
Happiness to the ghost.
Wait, I missed.
Happiness to the ghost and the skellies.
Cute.
Oh my gosh, so cute.
Any other happiness?
These are so cute too.
Can I get a balloon?
Oh no, I think he's...
Take my balloon.
I think he did that on purpose.
Ok guys, we can get our fortune told.
We can...
Whack-a-Fox?
Actually, I want to play Massacre.
I don't know why I'm asking.
Massacre!
Oh, it's free too.
Ok, nice.
One talent is that I can throw up on command.
Bounce!
Oh!
Oh my god, it's on fire!
Did no one else try playing it?
Good thing nobody was behind it.
How about Whack-a-Fox?
Oh my gosh, I can't wait.
Dangerous foxes.
Ok!
Whack them!
My reflexes are like a cat.
Only one?
Like
9 hits.
Play again?
Yes, yes.
Play again!
Reflexes!
Guys, we're fine.
Guys...
Something... There was dust in my eye.
There was dust in my eye.
Ghosts like... Ok, one more!
One more!
I'll beat my high score.
I'll beat my high score of 9.
Sorry.
Ok, I'm going to beat my high score.
I'm regressing.
I'm regressing for real?
It's gotta be... I can dance with it.
Ok, hold on.
Ok, I'm going to beat my score now for real.
Ok!
I
think I got the highest score you can get in this game.
4 is a spooky number.
9 is probably the max, maybe.
Probably.
I'm just that good at the game.
Can I get my fortune told?
Yes!
Oh wait, I have to use my reward ticket.
We can always get another one.
Ramirez Alejandra, and I want to know the future of me.
Please, thank you.
Thank you.
Once you see the beyond, the beyond sees you.
And you can be sure it will be coming for you.
The beyond is coming for me?
What's the beyond?
Want to try again?
Oh...
There's more?
Ok, I'll try it again.
We can always get more tickets.
What you see in the beyond is not what you see, but what you don't see.
Really?
Talk about crazy.
Crazy.
Yeah, I see the doll in the reward machine.
Don't worry, I'll get it.
Let's try one more.
Talk about crazy.
Get all your fortunes told.
Oh my gosh!
I got achievement.
Yeah, probably.
Too bad.
You didn't seem very sincere about that, huh?
It crashed.
Glitter to the crashed bird.
Three tickets!
Ok, we can get the golden chocolate coin.
So we'll get that.
Yummy!
Yummy.
Alright.
Ok, now let's go get five more tickets.
Let's go get five more tickets.
We got this.
We can play as many times as we want.
Yeah, play the game.
Ok, five more.
Five more.
I'm locked in.
Nine, baby!
Alright, play again.
Yeah!
Again!
What?
What do you mean I missed?
How did I miss?
What?
How did I miss that one though?
It threw me off completely.
Oh shoot!
Still got a ticket.
Yeah, I guess you're right.
Ok, now we have three.
Play two more times.
I'm too slow.
My reflexes today.
Usually I have reflexes like crazy, you guys.
Don't worry about it.
Alright, one more.
What do you do?
How did I miss?
How did you miss?
I got it correct!
Oh,
it won't even...
Win all reward tickets.
It won't even allow you to get anymore.
We cleared out the machine.
Maxed out, baby.
The most important one, the stoneware.
Say ten!
Thanks for the five gifts!
Oh my gosh!
Get it?
Because he's a rock.
And our doll.
Oh, one of those dolls again.
I want it.
Reality will transform into what the child desires the most.
Really?
Thanks for the ten gifts!
Thank you so much!
I like desires.
Nothing.
Why can't he see...oh buy everything.
Rich lady.
Why can't he see the dolls, I wonder.
I want to see the happy ghost one more time.
Let's keep on going.
Swan Lake.
No, our chocolate coin!
Or is that Swam Lake?
Swam Lake.
I'll take the next boat.
Surely it's a Halloween costume.
Thanks forever!
Thanks for four months caffeine!
One golden coin.
Why is she so violent?
You don't have to throw it at him.
Yeah, let's leave on the boat.
I think we got everything.
Oh yeah, those birds sucked.
The Kraken?
What's a Kraken with you?
Why don't...
Why don't you just explain it to her while you're on the boat?
Oh Kraken, if you appear in front of me, I will see you.
And if I see you, I will know it's you.
Sweet Kraken, come up in front of me right now.
What's a freaking Kraken?
She really is thinking about it forever.
This place is very quiet.
Is one allowed to talk?
It's getting awfully foggy.
Anyway, I was thinking, is the Kraken available for petting?
You know like, some pet doggies, some pet kitties.
I want to pet the Kraken, if it's possible.
Well, I heard you can lure it out with fish.
With fish you say?
Look Rodrigo, we need to talk.
I don't know what the Kraken is, but I'm very curious.
So I'll just place you here and see what happens.
Oh my God.
What's gonna happen?
Rodrigo!
What is this?
Oh my God, the Kraken!
We got rid of Rodrigo so fast.
We kept on to him this whole time.
We did that all day.
It's not my fault.
The fox stole it.
The fox?
Yeah, right.
Hey, Mysterious, are you taking me now to the house of Benjamin?
You know, that blue-eyed, soft, fluffy fox.
F for Rodrigo, I know it.
And stole my happiness?
You don't seem to want to talk about it.
And why is that you collect coins?
That's how you pay for your rent and food, right?
That was a chocolate coin.
It's probably delicious.
No, he wants to hear.
Anyway, do you like to eat Sushi?
Do you know about Sushi?
Because I have a Japanese ghost friend.
Oh, she said Japanese.
Anyway, can you speak Japanese?
I need some translations.
Do you know what this means?
Where is Kiri?
So you don't know, huh?
You know?
I've never been outside this late by myself.
Do you go outside by yourself this late everyday?
Are you going to eat my chocolate coin?
Because I'm a bit hungry.
Stop talking!
Why should I stop talking?
Nobody else is talking.
Hey, Mysterious, where are you going?
He's just like, I can't take it anymore!
Hello?
Can you swim?
No way!
He just dropped ship because she wouldn't shut up.
Ah, stupid.
I'm pretty sure he'll be fine.
Look, we have arrived.
Oh, we made it.
No, my ride!
Ok.
Guys, the music is awfully spooky here.
There's a bunch of toys here.
Check that out.
It's the toy graveyard.
I'm telling you.
Glitter to the toy graveyard.
Why is it so spooky?
What time is it?
It's getting really dark.
Mr. Voice, are you there?
Hello?
There's something wrong here.
Something very wrong.
What's wrong, Mr. Voice?
What do you mean?
It's coming.
Hide.
I don't know why you're playing, but if you scare me, I'll close my eyes.
Oh my gosh, the Barbie with the head cut off is so spooky.
What do you mean hide?
Hero!
That
was some good hopping.
We're going.
Where is Kiri?
Oh dammit.
My little foot got stuck.
Oh no, Miss Fortune.
Oh my God.
It's a monster.
Mr. Voice.
Can you see?
Oh my God.
What am I spamming?
Spam.
Oh my God, Quicktime event.
I got a nod off.
I don't think that was a fox.
You shut up.
Stop doubting me.
What's he recording?
Oh my god, he's recording the Blair Witch for real.
He's recording the Blair Witch.
Let's play dead.
Let's...let's...or...well actually I want to not listen to the narrator so let's get up.
Instead of playing dead let's get up.
Oh he helped me.
Hey!
Don't be rude.
Oh my god.
He's so stoic.
He's such a fox of few words.
He's a fox of so few words everybody.
No!
Unless she's just getting some exercise.
Benjamin.
Keep running after Benjamin.
Keep going.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Really?
You don't remember me saying if you keep running you'll end up hurt.
You put that there!
I know I could have been more specific.
Oh my god.
There's a bear trap up ahead.
Stop or you will be hurt.
But I felt like getting straight to the point.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
Who left a bear trap here anyway?
I haven't seen any bears.
Well, I don't want to point any fingers, but it was obviously the fox.
Obviously.
Fox-i-phobia.
Okay.
Alright.
Eternal happiness.
Right.
Okay.
Sparkles!
It's a happy...
It's a happy thing now.
Happy bear trap.
Yeah!
She just gave up her...
Yes, pay attention.
She just made up this whole lore.
Wait, when did Bubsy die?
Is Bubsy now in the bear trap?
No, okay.
Let's rip Bubsy I guess.
Yeah.
This one looks like a bird.
Oh, see all runestones.
What's primeve?
Because we gotta get rid of the beyond apparently.
Oh, we can't take it back.
Okay.
Well, oh!
We got a doll even.
Doll number six.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I can have my cake and eat it too.
Nothing.
She gets so defensive about it.
Oh my gosh, again?
The Aurora Borealis.
You guys, look!
Do you believe in love after love?
I believe in magic, yeah!
I do.
When mommy and daddy scream, I go to my secret hiding spot.
I've never seen those tricks those guys can do.
It's kind of crazy.
And it takes her two lives!
The narrator is so hot and cold with us.
Oh, let's just lie.
Let's say yeah.
So we don't hurt his feelings.
I mean, you know, we don't, but...
It's just so that he doesn't, you know, we don't want him to be like...
Oh, you don't trust me?
Easy.
You know?
Well, you know, I'm already dead.
But I want a human's perspective.
Are you guys afraid of dying?
I mean, you see ghosts before you, so...
Yeah.
Spoilers.
Seeing some no's, seeing some yeahs.
Depends on the day, but not before GTA 6.
And we'll say yeah before GTA 6.
Yes, I am.
I don't know if I will like being dead.
It's like too mysterious, you know?
What if I can't bring my glitter?
Mint 3.0?
But that's just tomorrow!
What about after tomorrow?
Oh no.
I hope it doesn't rain that much.
I don't like my feet getting wet.
I'm a little lady, you know?
I'm so chill.
She's a little lady.
Is this Benjamin's house?
Is this really his house?
Is this really his place?
Okay, here we go.
We don't want to get too wet, you know?
We love a handsy fox, huh?
Hi!
He's muscular, yeah, and his paws are soft.
A win, a win, a win.
She's so positive.
In woods.
What is this?
Oh yeah, he was recording earlier too.
He's building...
Oopsie.
Let's try later.
What's this?
Got some incense going into it.
Let's read Benjamin's diary.
We gotta know the Benjamin lore.
If he took our happiness, we can take his secrets, okay?
Yulhanelios?
Oh my god, it's actually Benjamin.
No way.
Confidence.
I travel from Sensirty to Pandora when fog appears.
Hasn't the kid, the Japanese kid been saying, where's the fog?
And also, Sensirty is also the place that I mentioned.
The Sensirty is what gets rid of the beyond.
I pack things and food.
No information on how long stay.
I rent cabin until work done.
Where's the fog?
Yeah!
My task important.
Boss told me many victims in town.
I need courage.
After long walk in fog, I arrived city, called Openfields.
Tiny town has good forest.
Cabin very nice, has TV, kitchen.
I sleep sofa.
I decorate cabin.
Fish bells smell funny.
I ate mushrooms.
Mushrooms in woods.
I refresh after sleep.
Try find parasite.
Did not find it.
Day one fail.
Many victims gone missing in Parasite game.
Parasite game, huh?
I can't help.
Who are the victims?
What game?
And is afraid of the Parasite?
Feel sad.
I send message to boss.
Some victims not coming to Sinircity.
I see Parasite.
It scared me.
Also not eat more mushrooms.
Stomach ache and much gas.
Oh no!
Is no good.
Don't eat this mushroom again.
Mushrooms serious danger.
Oh no!
Not feel good.
Danger mushroom.
I stay home.
Cut wood and do tea and root soup.
Good taste.
Oh no!
I do dolls for victim and pictures.
If she sees them, good.
Parasite recognized.
Morgo code P0101222.
It likes to play.
I has guide for steps.
Purge tomorrow.
Now rest until stomach good.
Morgo, Morgo.
Feeling no stomach aches, only gas.
Is a gassy fox, you guys.
Morgo know I'm here.
Morgo play old trick many times now.
But it make mistake.
One victim can hear its voice inside her head.
Victim code Misfortune.
Is nice code.
Morgo can't have her say boss.
She must be rescued.
But I follow steps.
I saw Morgo take shape.
Scary.
She doesn't recognize her own name.
Oh my gosh!
So cute!
She looks like Animal Crossing character.
Boss send me message.
Watch victim house.
I sleep outside.
Hiding.
Trash.
I fail find parasite.
It did not come today.
Big trouble.
Misfortune watch me.
Strange.
Big trouble?
Misfortune?
But that's me.
I bet he's in love with me.
Oh my gosh!
See there's hearts around him.
There's hearts around him.
Why she see me?
She big eyes.
I run away.
Felt warm in stomach.
Maybe mushrooms tickle again.
Does he actually like her back?
I see Morgo play old trick again.
Victim don't realize all is again.
All is again!
Must courage and stop parasite this time.
I send many victims to Sinnersity.
I got level 2 protector.
I confident.
Now I has prime illumination cane.
Oh sorry.
Prim-Eve illumination cane.
I try prim-Eve illumination cane in woods.
Fun.
I feel courage.
Practicing to help Misfortune.
I see she makes too much talk.
I think she fun and strong.
Mint big eyes too.
Hey!
Do you like me?
Oh my gosh.
Morgo confused by charms of Misfortune.
I did video picking, wood and parasite game.
But I'm courage now.
I scared only little.
Yes, I know how to talk.
He loves me.
She's a yapper.
I message boss I'm doing it today.
All steps followed.
Prepared breakfast tea.
Funny feeling with tea.
Herbs from woods are fun.
I'm courage and confident today.
I ready.
If Bengi has a boss, he has a job.
Then I can be married to him.
He has a job.
Fix the TV.
Happiness to the video player.
I hope I haven't missed any.
Oh gosh.
I'm nervous.
What does he play?
It looks like Benjamin likes to educate himself.
I like that in a fox.
Meaning of love.
The fun stories of a boring man.
When hatred wants to be loved.
He loves you.
He was really lonely I think.
The upside of being a spirit animal.
Communication.
Key to cooperation.
Learning how to be...
Oh I thought this was something else.
Learning how to be great.
Death after life.
We got Bengi's playlist.
Oh this is tea.
What's the tea?
That tea smells like roses and lemon.
Great fox!
You guys stop it.
Drink Benjamin's tea?
Yeah, let's drink it.
Why is everything in this...
Oh no, is it the mushrooms?
Why is everything in this game poisonous?
Oh my god.
Oh they are on their little date.
Oh I want PB&J.
I'll have that for dinner.
Why is he got flies around him?
Stinky ass.
Go take a shower.
Ew.
Why are you drooling?
Is this what love is like?
It's disgusting.
It's messy.
Oh my god.
Yeah, again.
Wait, but Benji is here.
No!
Benji, no!
You threw up in his house.
Oh, peanut butter.
Yummy.
That's how Mata talks about herself in her stinky GFU.
No!
Mata is the only stinky one.
Tara Khan.
Oh, sick hat.
We got some paint here.
We got some stinky socks.
Oh my gosh.
He's still eating his mushrooms.
Why does he keep ignoring us?
What are you...
What are you doing?
Is this a kiss?
Oh my god.
Is this really happening?
What the fox?
What is he doing?
What is that?
Your diary.
I'm sorry if you're upset because I read it, but I was curious.
Is it the monster in your diary you're afraid of?
I think I saw him too.
Look at his little paws.
So cute!
So cute.
Oh my gosh.
You can't hide the children.
Let's follow Benjamin.
Are you rescuing me Benjamin?
Like if I was a girl in trouble?
Oh my gosh, we are a damsel in distress.
We are a lady in...
What's a bad thing that starts with L?
A lady in...
Oh!
Lost?
No!
Liability.
Yeah, we are a lady in liability.
In lament.
Oh my gosh, he got a haircut.
Are you gonna take it?
Oh no, is this Benjamin?
Benjamin.
Sparkle to the hair.
There's a secret passage.
There's a hole behind the painting.
Hello.
I love the way she says hello.
It's so funny.
Oh, there's a chair here.
Such a clever little lady.
Oh, never mind.
We need the chair.
Nice.
Hold on, is there anything else besides weapons and such?
We made our choice guys.
We can't go back upstairs.
Time to use my ninja skills.
Yes!
What a bad crack.
Be quiet.
This is a ninja mission.
Benjamin, are you here?
Why did it keep happening?
Oh my gosh, was it the tea?
No, the tea!
So it was Benjamin placing these, but Benjamin seems so nice.
Maybe he put them for that monster.
No, probably, right?
Not for us.
Oh, there's food.
Can of fish balls?
This is like sushi balls.
Not quite, I think.
I'm getting hungry though.
Not because of the fish balls.
Let's take this key.
Looks important.
A picture of a key.
Interesting.
Or it's just a picture?
Wait...
Can we not grab it?
My ninja senses are telling me to climb up on this chair.
Don't watch the fire!
Watch the fire!
Oh my gosh.
A real ninja lady always touches everything.
A secret button.
Secret button, oh yeah.
Press the button baby!
Alright then, I push the button.
See guys, we had to do it anyway.
Ninja lady touches everything!
That was easy.
Too easy.
We're too good at this game.
Oh my god, microwave oven.
You've been knocked down before.
Yeah, you can do this Miss Fortune!
Did you let that stop you?
Yeah, keep getting up!
Get up Miss Fortune.
You can do it.
Yeah, she's just pep-talking herself.
Because...
Because you are...
Miss Fortune!
Because...
You're a strong little lady!
You are the little lady Miss Fortune!
I love that part, so sweet.
Maybe we shouldn't talk to Mr. Voice anymore.
Why did Benji leave us anyway?
We can pet the deer.
We can finally pet it!
Oh my gosh!
I'm so happy!
Glitter to the baby deer!
I once tried that and it almost kicked me in the face.
I probably would have died a second time.
I'm gonna eat some snacks.
I hope it's ok guys.
Bye!
Very sucky.
What's snack time?
Just some calorie made out of my desk.
She actually figured it out.
Stop this nonsense.
We have to keep playing my game.
You can't make me.
Yes, I can.
Stop that.
Then play with me.
You need to find your eternal happiness.
I'll give you a clue.
It's at home, waiting for you.
I'm sick of that eternal happiness.
I don't want it anymore.
You can't say that.
That would break the rules.
You heard me.
I don't want the eternal happiness anymore.
Tell him.
I won't tolerate this behavior.
I'll be waiting for you at home.
Now, tell me where Benjamin is.
What do you do to him?
Freaking monster.
Let's pet the deer for good luck.
Take Benjamin's stuff.
Let's see what's inside.
Maybe a clue where to find Benjamin.
Oh, we got another doll.
Doll number 7.
At the end of the road, you will realize you already signed the deal.
No!
We already signed the deal!
Oh my god, stop.
Baby Benjamin.
The game was rigged from the start.
This is really mysterious.
Ok, ok, this is a lot.
For students of the University of Senescedist Technology.
Protector course 3-step guide.
3-step guide to exterminate parasitic things from the beyond.
Introduction.
As the ultra-reality forms in hand with the concept of time, new realms outside the constituted free 5 realms of essential existence have appeared.
After the ultra-war.
This is some crazy lore.
What's the ultra-war?
Thousands of beings were discovered as byproducts of the war.
They created for themselves a new realm.
We refer to it as the beyond.
The beyond is, in simple terms, a place of extreme absurdity with no logical laws of physics.
Erin, thanks for 3 months.
Thank you.
We can't allow such beings inside the free at the moment, since the foundation of our reality is based in the energetic and ethical values of the ultra-reality before the ultra-war.
The beyond is still a misunderstood realm.
We haven't yet found the pieces to connect with it in a logical manner.
The few patterns we recognize are the behaviors of some visitors, also known as parasites.
They normally enter the third reality, aka Pandora, and seek fresh meat to lure into the beyond.
And that's why we need the protectors.
The protectors are the only ones with the capability of seeing the imbalance between realities and using the tools available inside the ultra-reality.
Protectors will help victims and guide them into senescity.
The guidance provided in this book must be followed with great responsibility.
Never skip a step.
For each victim the protector returns to senescity, the protector will be rewarded with new levels, tools, and more steps to follow.
The Parasite Step 1.
The protector must locate the victims and the parasite.
Protector's Parasite Case P0101222 Morgul Evaluate if the victim is in need of assistance.
If so, then proceed to Step 2.
Need of Assistance Checklist The victim has forgotten his or her identity.
The victim is already dead but doesn't realize it.
The victim believes the illusions of the beyond are real.
The victim sympathizes with the parasite.
Checklist of Parasite
P0101222 Morgul Looking cute today, Mint.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
I'll look even cuter tomorrow.
Thank you for 6 months, Dione.
1.
Deforms reality into absurdity.
2.
Parasite seems friendly yet it lures the victim to play dangerous games.
3.
Its shape shifts into a human-animal creature.
4.
It quickly learns about the environment.
Language and culture are not an issue for this parasite.
5.
Large flocks of black birds will appear near the parasite.
These birds are the eyes of Morgul, giving him an overview of his playing ground.
Step 2.
Oh my gosh, this is a lot.
Use the surroundings to help the victim become aware of the parasite.
The protector can, for example, write and paint simple messages in public spaces to increase awareness.
It is strictly forbidden to interact directly with the victim.
Oh, that's why he doesn't talk to us.
It could lead to irreversible trauma inside the victim's mind.
If the parasite kills the victim, you will need to proceed to Step 3 immediately.
Step 3.
Prepare for direct contact with...
With the what?
Now I will never know.
Oh no.
We'll never know.
Let's...
Happiness to the broken bag!
Okay.
I sure hope I didn't miss any.
I guess we'll see.
What are we having direct contact with?
Oh my gosh.
That was some crazy lore, right?
He's earned his degree, this fox.
That's where he was.
Okay.
Oh wait.
Wait, can I go back in?
Oh, no.
I guess...
Hopefully there was nothing else.
Now when I look at this, I can see what Benjamin tried to warn me about.
He knew all along, such a foxy boy.
Foxy boy.
She's so cute.
He was trying to warn us, you guys.
What?
He was just trying to warn us.
Scary, there's no one here.
She's so funny.
Mhm.
I wonder where that wolf is.
Gasp.
Uh -huh, Miss Fortune.
Thanks, Miss Fortune.
Miss Fortune.
Thanks, other Miss Fortune.
I do that too.
Crazy how different the game can be.
Potato.
Why does he keep showing up?
Chungkingosaurus.
Oh, he's got a little heart.
Oh my god, how fast can I color this?
Oh my god, speedrun.
Speedrun the paintings.
Speedrun the coloring book.
Done.
Next.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Speedrun, speedrun.
Done.
Next.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
He's got a little butterfly.
Sprilophosaurus.
I got an achievement for painting all the paintings.
I gamed.
Why does he gotta wear this alien mask?
Konbanwa.
Konichiwa.
Today is the first time.
Wait, what does it say?
Beware of the consequences?
Hero!
Oh my god.
Help Hero!
We couldn't save him.
Hero!
It's ok.
You have us with you.
So true.
Very long sigh.
Are you gonna kick this all the way?
Are you gonna kick it again?
Happiness to the glitter.
Look at all those birds in the background.
Look at all the birds in the background.
Oh my god.
Ok, keep going.
Yeah, that was awesome.
Toki just promote my 3.0?
Glitter!
Let's keep kicking the glitter.
Oh wait, other way.
Other way.
Keep kicking.
No.
Oh, kick the can three times.
Wow.
Wait, how many times do I kick it before I get another achievement?
What if I kick it ten times?
Oi.
Golden can at a hundred kicks.
Who wants...ok.
Lucky can.
This could be you.
Ok, I just kicked you.
Who wants the next kick?
That one's you.
This one's you.
Ok, I think I've maybe gotten as many as I can get.
Oh, look at all these teenagers.
Excuse me.
I'm talking over here.
Well, if that's how you treat little ladies, then give yourself a fuck.
Yeah, don't ignore me.
Ah, glitter in your eyes.
Why they gotta ignore us?
Yeah, you tell them.
You tell them, misfortune.
Oh gosh, look at all the birds, you guys.
Oh my god.
Oh, hello?
Is my house haunted?
Oh gosh, my house is evil.
Yeah, nice.
Oh my god.
What's that sound?
Taro didn't make it.
Now he's going to get isekai'd to the Disney universe.
Oh wait, he's going to be a kid genius.
Might be better though.
What is that sound?
Hello?
Smells like something dragging.
So scary.
Why is my house like this?
Benji?
Hey, I played your game.
That's not your responsibility.
Don't put that on a little girl.
We are doing another game?
Oh my god.
Gary doesn't love you.
I don't commit.
Oh, oh.
What's that?
What's the new game?
We are starting the new game all over again.
I'm taking the unicorn this time.
Yes, Sparkle!
Oh ho ho.
Oh yeah.
No, she's a yapper.
This person would be a great VTuber.
You liar.
No deal.
No.
Benji?
No!
He doesn't...
He doesn't know anything!
Can we go in here?
Wait, we can...
Yeah, I do that.
What about Benjamin?
Can we dance?
Oh my god.
Wait, what did it say?
You're stuck forever?
Oh, that's...
Monster's music forever.
She's not dancing!
OK.
What's in here?
Abstute observation.
Can we take the rock?
No.
OK.
Misfortune is so smart.
OK, I'm just gonna play his game one last time.
No!
Don't run there.
Double click to run!
Stop it!
Oh my god.
Oh no, not again.
You promised he wouldn't be like last time.
That was a beautiful example of cause and effect.
No, you lied to me.
I don't want to play this game anymore.
Fine, let me come up with a new game to play.
New game.
Knock, knock.
Who's there?
No, I don't want to play with you anymore.
Yeah, she's literally that meme.
Knock, knock.
Who's there?
Oh my god, the voice.
Oh god, you're scaring me.
Stop it.
Leave me alone.
Oh my god.
Can I answer the door?
Go, go, go!
Oh, it just repeats guys.
OK.
We can go hide.
Yeah, of course.
Oh my god, run.
Run!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you're stupid.
You're a stupid ghost.
You don't even know how to open doors.
Stoney!
Throw it at his face!
Roar!
Oh my god.
Roar XD
Stoney!
Oh my god.
Toxic relationship.
Stop being so jealous.
Yeah, get out of my house.
Get out.
Scary.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He's kind of awesome though.
No!
You tell him.
She's so brave.
No!
Leave me alone.
Benjamin!
Yeah man.
She's here.
Oh god.
She's so...
She's so hopeless.
Even with this demonic creature in front of her, she's like...
Oh my god.
He's so muscular.
Yeah, kick his ass Benjamin!
Why is he hot though?
No!
He's hot, but he's weak.
Benjamin!
Got taken out by a dang little fox.
Benjamin or the beast?
The beast!
Right?
You guys meant the beast, right?
Be aware.
Did the day start over?
Misfortune!
Her secret hiding spot is all...
Is everything back to normal now?
There's a doll on the ground now.
Benji?
Are you around?
I guess I have to reveal this.
I'll make some improvements.
But first, I want to thank Benjamin.
Glitter to our broken fort!
All the birds are gone.
Wait, where did our other doll go?
Find doll number 8.
I wonder how many...
I assume this is all of them, right?
Morko is coming.
Benjamin, open your eyes.
He's the voice in your head driving you mad.
Maybe this should be doll number 1.
I think whoever labeled these dolls...
I think this should be the first one that we find.
Why did you save this for last?
It's like they don't...
Yeah, it's like they don't even want you to be saved.
They don't even want you to be saved because they don't tell you what's going on.
Oh my god.
Whose job was that?
Get them fired.
Grandma...
Oh my god, the vase is...
It's still broken.
It's really peaceful though, all the bird sounds.
Benjamin must be a fox onion.
Oh, the soup.
Oh, mom?
Mommy?
I'm back.
Don't ignore me.
Are you angry because I couldn't get the happiness for you?
What's happening?
Mommy?
This must be a bad dream.
We can't sparkle anymore.
Is that...
Was
it you?
Oh, her glitter.
Poor baby.
Look at his awkward smile.
What's this?
What's happening?
We need to go?
Alright.
Mommy, are glitters right here?
I can't tell if it's the mom or the dad that hit her though.
He's like okay.
He has such a way with words.
Mom was cooking, so was dad.
He's like waving at the mom.
He's like hi mom.
I miss you.
It's so sad.
Not her being like I was your little misfortune.
It has like a double meaning and all.
Like misfortune, like M-I-S-S fortune.
And also misfortune, like your bad thing.
I don't think they really wanted her to begin with because...
It's so sad.
Yes, that's the point.
I know, I'm just saying.
It's just so sad.
Gosh.
Okie dokie, here we go.
Time to see if I got all the sparkles or not.
So sad.
Wait, stop, Benjamin.
Where are we going?
Oh my gosh, I can still sparkle.
Ok, we're walking.
And I'm sparkling.
And I'm walking.
I'm running.
Oh my god!
Ah, the puppy!
I'm going puppy, I'm going.
Brisk jog.
Oh my gosh, it's so cute.
Oh my god, pinecone people.
RPG party right here.
Oh, he runs when I run too.
Speed up, dog!
Oh my god, Grim Warper.
That's the Grim Reaper, but a worm.
Kick the dog, keep going.
Push the dog to go faster.
Pigapines.
Centipedes, but pigs.
Run, run, run!
Run!
Would not bring me joy.
I'm feeling Benjamin, where the hell are we going?
Benjamin, are you sure this is the good afterlife?
Benjamin?
Oh my god, Dapper Skelly.
I kinda love that guy actually.
Why was he setting the berries on fire though?
Run!
One last sparkle!
Bonser Skelly.
This place is really cold.
Good thing you got a jacket.
Oh.
We finally pet the dog!
Ok.
We must ring the tree.
Oh, my bad.
Here we go.
Oh.
Uncover all the sparkles!
Oh, we did it!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, lucky!
Doll number 9.
All around disasters seem to disappear.
The weird messed up way the parasite...more of a paternal figure, yeah.
Deep inside the fog you defeat him!
That guy is dead.
True ending time!
Oh my god!
Little lady!
She is so brave.
There she goes.
Lady Death is kinda hot.
She is single?
Oh my gosh, it's you guys!
There you go!
Where are you gonna go with your new freedom?
What are you gonna do?
I don't think I've ever seen the true end before for this.
The happiness went to the mom!
She took off her mask!
Give mommy the eternal happiness.
Why is she smiling?
Your kid just died.
Wait, what?
Wait, that didn't make me feel any better.
Um...
Win the game.
Going for the MILF.
Classic Wisp move.
My kid is dead, let's go!
Because she knows she is in a happy place.
Maybe she knew that she was a terrible mother.
It's kinda like, maybe she's smiling because she got away with it.
It's so messed up!
I know, right?
I feel like maybe she knew she was a bad mom and just didn't know how to...
She was stuck in a cycle and didn't know how to change it.
And then she was like, oh, my kid is in a better place.
But that's a little soon to be smiling.
She's not even buried yet.
She's like still on the ground.
Like, damn, the body is still warm!
Like...
Come on!
Yikes forever.
I don't know if that ending made me feel any better or not.
Dang, I thought the true end would make me be like, yeah!
City dropped the charges, let's go!
All she had to be like is, wait, wait, wait.
My kid is in a better place.
And you'd be like, oh, yeah.
You know what, you're so right.
And then all is forgiven.
That was not at all cathartic.
I was sprinkling everything.
We gave mommy the eternal happiness by not existing anymore.
You know what, that mom didn't deserve a little misfortune.
Because she was just too cute.
She got Isekai to become a Vtuber.
I'm a little lady too.
Hold on, Minto.
Oh my gosh, lady.
Thanks for three months.
If it's the dad that hit misfortune, double happiness I guess.
Yeah, she gets out of a marriage, she gets out of having a kid.
She's just like, I get to start all over.
Yeah, but it's so messed up too.
Because misfortune was just like a little kid.
She didn't even get to live her life.
You know, you live with the mistakes that you made because you're an adult, mom.
But let the kid live her life.
Finally a parrot worse than me.
Huey.
Nah, Huey.
You still get to keep that title.
Thanks for the six months.
Kid gave her super magical happiness.
Not her fault she's suddenly happy.
That's true, it was supernatural happiness.
She couldn't control it, I suppose.
Yeah, Huey still is the worst parent.
Not that saying.
Not saying a pro-Huey.
No, we're never, we're not, no pro-Huey here.
My client's child is being taken care of by Lady Death now, who is hot.
I rest my case.
Hey Minto, it's my aunt's birthday.
Oh my gosh!
Happy birthday John's aunt!
Or do you say aunt?
It's your aunt.
Oh, it was a typo.
No, we're not pro-Huey.
Music forever.
Music you can dance to forever.
Is there an after?
Cinematics, oh the dolls.
Oh, they all look different.
That's cute.
So there were only nine of them?
Art gallery.
Oh, cute.
Oh, these are so cute!
Oh, I love this one.
I love this one.
Fantasmagoria.
Oh, it's scary.
This one's so sweet too.
Oh, cute.
It's the first animal she got to pet was the deer.
A dream come true.
Oh, these must be...
Okay, so these are all the backgrounds.
That would be the title screen.
Yeah, because we had this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, so fun.
And then the cinematics.
Oh, we missed one.
I wonder what it would have been.
Oh, it's the...
Because we got the house of horrors, this is the carousel.
Or sorry, the marigold carousel, yeah.
That must be it.
Kind of a solid hit right in the feels.
Guess we needed to cause more chaos.
No, I think it's because we remember at the Fantasmagoria we could only pick one ride.
So it was either the haunted house or the carousel and we chose the haunted house.
Well, I did.
I executive ordered the haunted house.
But we got all the other ones, nice.
We like nearly feel... I wonder if I like 100%ed this.
Or almost.
Let's see, what's...
Oh, no.
26 out of 35.
Let's see what achievements.
Hit the alarm.
Sniper?
What alarm?
Doggy treat is give the cutie a treat.
Rotten fish, bury Rodrigo.
We could have buried him.
Little cutie, learn the name of the puppy.
Read your fortune cookie.
When the hell do these happen?
Dance the entire song.
Don't fix the vase.
Ride all the rides.
Oh wait, I could have ridden both rides.
I got cheated.
I honestly thought at the start that the narrator would be Death the Grim Reaper watching over her.
Not some Wendigo-Eyed Skinwalker looking at her.
Yeah.
You kind of get that vibe from him.
But it's not... He seems so like innocent in the beginning.
But he definitely shows his colors mid-game.
Yeah.
The beast from over the garden wall.
Right!
And then the last achievement is...
Ride the twister until you puke.
Doesn't seem like there's any hidden ones.
Oh, I got most of them though.
I got 26 out of 35.
Nice.
This game is so sweet.
So sad.
It's sad, but it's like...
And it has like obviously really dark themes to it, but...
It doesn't feel... Like it's a little whimsy.
It's got some sort of whimsy about it.
That kind of like makes it feel not so bad.
Like it's easy to joke about it, I suppose, you know.
Read the dolls?
They have new me... Oh, they do?
No, it doesn't.
Everything begins with the song of a Jackdaw.
These are the same lines as before.
Unloved children.
They receive a gift from the beyond.
Yeah, these are all the same.
Morgul.
Deep inside the fog you defeat them.
All good.
Oh my gosh, guys.
Tomorrow...
Is my...
Pre-debut.
I just want it to happen now.
Oh gosh, tomorrow is going to be so slow for me.
I'm just going to be sitting in my room.
Just wiggling back and forth like...
Is it time?
No.
Even though not everything is done.
So, you know, maybe I should have everything finished first.
And then be like...
Is it time?
No.
Guerrilla pre-debut.
Yeah, what if I just did it right now?
Screw having the planned debut.
What if I did it now?
It's crazy too because I announced it a month ago.
So I've just been like...
Twiddling my thumbs for an entire month.
Finally, tomorrow.
Super mega ultra hype.
Woohoo, tomorrow.
Oh my gosh, give us a tease.
No.
No tease.
Tomorrow.
I can be patient for just 24 more hours.
Even less than 24 more hours.
I can be patient for one more day.
Thank you, Minto 2.0.
Tomorrow is going to be...
There might be some scuff though.
Because I didn't quite plan a script for some stuff.
So...
We'll just see how...
I'll just wing it as I always do, baby.
Thank you, Minto 2.0.
What a stream to have as my last 2.0 one, huh?
Well, full 2.0.
You'll still see me tomorrow like this a little bit.
Thank you for everything.
Hopefully not too much scuff though.
I have some cool things to show off.
Yeah.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Well, I'm going to go then so I can sleep.
And then tomorrow will come faster.
Thank you.
This game had a lot of funny and strange parts.
And I think that made the stuff near the end hit harder.
Thanks for playing, Minto.
Really excited for tomorrow.
Thank you.
The... Oh, the Ghostbusters Krispy Kreme.
I have seen it.
I didn't try it though.
I didn't try it.
Yeah, I think about this game...
The one thing I really love about games is when they're very silly.
And then also very emotional, I guess.
I don't want to say sad.
But like, you know...
Like Metal Gear.
Sorry, I talked about Metal Gear a lot today.
I've been having withdrawals of talking about Metal Gear, I think, recently.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Can't wait for 3.0 tomorrow.
Thank you.
One more bust in for 2.0.
Yeah, we should.
Actually...
So every time I do...
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
Actually, I'm going to go to my maid cafe.
Real quick.
One second.
Quit the game.
Oh, it froze.
Hello?
Quit the game.
Oh, it froze.
Oh, the game is not responding.
When I play Bustin' now, my stream gets copyrighted.
Or like...
Yeah, so it's kind of annoying.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, so...
Like what I did with the karaoke and everything...
Hold on, let me control...
Oh, close the program.
Never mind.
So that's why I haven't been doing it so much.
Because every stream has been getting claimed with it, so...
But this one is okay.
We can for one last one with...
Oh, hold on.
With the 2.0.
Okay.
What a bother.
I know, right?
Da-da-da-da-da...
Where is it?
I'll turn it down low just a little bit.
Thank you for the 20 gifts!
Thank you!
If there is something strange...
Sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Teresa, thank you!
VOD gang tomorrow.
So happy Halloween.
So happy Halloween!
Oh my gosh.
If I stream for one more hour, we would have gotten Halloween.
Busted, busted, busted...
Can you hear it okay at least?
Just a little bit maybe.
If you're saying thanks...
Sleeping in your bed.
Invisible bed.
Sleeping in...
Let me tell you something.
Busted, busted, busted...
Feel good, feel good, feel good...
Freaky ghost man!
Freaky man baby!
Let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good!
I'm gonna sleep.
Oh my gosh, I hope I can sleep tonight.
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
I'm gonna be too excited.
I won't be able to sleep.
An invisible man.
Oh, bed.
Sleep.
Freaky ghost bed.
Oh my god, I got the lyrics wrong.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Busted, busted, busted...
Makes me feel good, feel good...
Feel good, feel good, feel good...
Sorry I can't make it to Atlanta to be there for you.
It's all good!
Here's five bucks.
Pick me next time when you buy your next pack of smokes.
Oh, I just ran out.
Thanks, cool.
I'll do that.
Busted, busted...
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
Busted, busted, busted...
Makes me feel good, feel good...
Feel good, feel good, feel good...
I hope you guys had a fun Halloween month.
I'm glad we got to play lots of Halloween spooky games and do some Halloween activities like the cookies and everything.
Have a great night, and I'll see you guys tomorrow in my new fall!
Let's do my stand.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Otsumito!
Bye!
Itadakimasu!
Wait, let me make sure that it's not...
I've been like, obviously testing stuff out.
Okay, good.
It's not the new one.
Okay, bye bye!